Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
So.
Exzellente.
Lass mich mal etwas entspannteres anmachen.
Ich bin ein bisschen zu laut jetzt.
Oh.
Mein Browser ist gecrashed.
Warum macht er denn sowas?
Nee, doch nicht.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
So, ich muss noch was trinken erstmal hier.
Ich muss meinen Tee noch hertrinken.
Weil nachts
dehydriert man ja immer ein bisschen.
Aber nix trinkt, weil man pennt.
So.
What the fuck?
Okay, es ist ein Docker-File.
Afglo-Klein. Ich war schon Afglo.
Afgpoggers.
So, Pillen habe ich auch schon genommen.
Excellent.
So.
Chat.
Nitta ist down.
Ich habe doch immer gerne hier
Hier, guckt mal.
Ich hab doch immer gerne hier Twitter-Messages auf Nitta mir angeguckt, weil Twitter so kacke ist, wenn du nicht eingeloggt bist.
Leider, also X, formerly known as Twitter.
Leider wurden die jetzt cease and desist vor zwei, drei Tagen.
Das heißt jetzt kann man Nitta nicht mehr verwenden.
Das sagt, weil Twitter ist ja ohne Login nicht mehr richtig zu benutzen.
Das Massive Sack.
Guck hier, ich hab's hier sogar noch offen.
Guck hier.
Ach, Moment.
Das geht bestimmt nicht mehr.
Das ist bestimmt ein Bug. Das hab ich noch im Cache.
Ja, ja, genau. Guck, das hab ich noch im Cache gehabt.
So sah das aus.
Also man konnte quasi Twitter richtig ordentlich benutzen.
Aber, wisst ihr, was noch viel nicer ist?
Ob wir gerade dabei sind?
Dass Twitter wieder Zeug sperrt.
Ich habe letztens auf Hacker News gelesen, dass irgendwie einer eine Twitter...
Oh, hat das Ding, hat das hier eine gescheite Suche?
Show?
Ne.
Ähm, ich habe auf...
Dass irgendeiner einen XX- bzw. Twitter-Reader gebaut hat.
Da findet man nicht.
Ich, mal gucken, ob ich den auch finde
Twitter-Viewer, hier
Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das auch funktioniert
Hahaha
Geil
Ist auch
Der hat das erst vor vier Tagen gepostet
Scheiße, Alter
Der hat das erst vor vier Tagen
Auf Hackernews gepostet, dass er das jetzt
Neu, neu gebaut hat
Scheiße, Mann
Nix hier
Ja, das ist aber richtig räulich, Alter.
Man kann...
Das Ding ist halt...
Man kann halt X nicht mal gescheit lesen, ohne eingeloggt zu sein.
Guck.
Guck hier.
Komplett.
Kompletter Random...
Kompletter Random Crap, was der mir hier anzeigt.
Kannst du auch nicht hier...
Das ist halt voll für den Arsch.
Ich weiß nur, Nitta kann man auch selbst hosten.
Ja, geil.
Da ist halt kaum einer.
Ich will ja explizit Twitter lesen.
Eine alternative Plattform bringt mir da nichts.
Wie hat Nitta das gemacht?
Ich würde mal sagen, die haben gewebscraped, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
Oder die haben halt irgendwelche internen Twitter-APIs benutzt
Weil letztendlich muss ja Twitter selbst, muss ja auch die Posts für die Webseite irgendwie abrufen
Wahrscheinlich haben die geguckt, also ich gehe mal davon aus, die haben einfach geguckt, was macht die Webseite
Und haben dann einen Server gebaut, die im Endeffekt die Endpunkte benutzt, die sonst halt die Webseite benutzt, um Nachrichten abzurufen
Das geht schon.
Ja, das, also ne, kann man ja mal hier zum Beispiel, guck mal mal hier, wenn wir jetzt hier auf X, machen wir doch hier mal, ja, Inspect.
Network, zack.
So, jetzt wächst FPS.
Ähm, X.
So, zack.
Guck hier, erstmal 30 Milliarden JavaScript-Dinger runtergeladen, ey.
WTF, hört man, das hört, seht ihr mal, das hört gar nicht auf.
Aber immerhin sind es nur, nur,
oh mein Gott, Transferred.
Wir müssen das Disable Cache machen.
Und nochmal.
Warum switcht das rüber?
Weiß man nicht so genau.
Es geht, guck mal.
Es sind nur 6 MB Resources.
Das ist relativ leichtgewichtig.
Wir haben letztens mal bei YouTube geguckt.
Ich glaube, YouTube waren 20 MB oder sowas.
Äh doch doch man kann schon lesen
Aber die Webseite ist halt kacke
Die Webseite ist halt kacke
Das ist halt Frontend beschränkungsmäßig
So und jetzt können wir mal gucken
Was die hier beispielsweise machen
Sofern ich hier irgendwie durchblicke was die da treiben
Wenn man das hier jetzt analysiert
Kommt man bestimmt dahinter
Keksor
kommt man bestimmt dahinter, was sie da eigentlich machen.
Aber das ist mir jetzt zu kompliziert.
Ja, das macht ja nichts.
Aber die müssen ja trotzdem irgendeine API benutzen,
die Webseite, um die Nachrichten abzufragen.
So, und wenn ich die jetzt selbst abfrage,
dann kann ich ja mit den Daten, die da rauskommen,
machen, was ich will.
So hat das Nitter höchstwahrscheinlich auch gemacht.
Das Projekt selber...
...gibt es, glaube ich, noch auf...
Ach, guck mal, der hat es auch 26, dann hat er es auch archivt.
Ja, kacke, ne?
Gibt es das hier noch?
Ah, das ist YouTube.
Ja, Zedke.
Wird immer beschissener.
Ich habe nicht Angst zu wechseln.
Ich will die Sachen auf Twitter lesen.
Das bringt mir ja nichts, wenn ich selbst auf eine andere Plattform gehe.
Wenn das, was ich lesen will, nicht auf einer anderen Plattform ist.
Auf welche Rechtsgrundlage eigentlich?
Ich vermute mal, das ist...
Moment, wo haben wir hier...
Ich vermute mal, das ist Kona.
Ich habe einfach mehr Geld und mehr Anwälte als du, Rechtsgrundlage.
würde ich jetzt einfach mal vermuten.
Ob das im Prozess standhalten würde,
keine Ahnung.
Aber bei den Amis, wer mehr Geld und mehr Anwälte hat,
kriegt ja in der Regel auch recht.
Nicht immer, aber bei so Dingern ist halt die Frage,
möchte sich irgendein random Typ,
der privat
so ein Projekt nebenbei bastelt,
wirklich mit X und
Elons Anwälten auseinandersetzen.
Ich denke mal, die meisten wollen das eher nicht.
deswegen kann er das einfach machen
und
hat keiner Bock
dagegen zu halten, was ich auch durchaus
verstehen kann, ja
wahrscheinlich auch kein Bock drauf
so
jetzt müssen wir erstmal den Mini-PC einschalten
dann müssen wir
was müssen wir dann machen, Leute
was ist Pflicht
wenn wir unsere Linux-Mini-PC einschalten
einmal die Woche.
Das Allerwichtigste, was gleich gemacht werden muss.
Also nachdem er hochgefahren ist.
Moin.
Updaten. Richtig.
Ich wollte eigentlich drauf raus, dass man
Reboot machen muss.
Ey, ich hab auch
letztens auf Twitter wieder
ganz merkwürdige,
Also man kriegt ja auf Twitter, kannst ja auswählen, ob du so ein Newsfeed, also deine Startseite im Endeffekt, kannst ja auswählen, ob du nur News sehen willst von Leuten, denen du followst oder halt auch irgendwelche Dinger, wo Twitter meint, dass sich das interessiert.
So.
Und da habe ich irgendeinen Post empfohlen bekommen.
Da sind teilweise übelste Random-Posts dabei, wo ich mich frage, okay, interessiert es mich jetzt?
Aber da habe ich letztens einen Post bekommen, da hat sich irgendjemand auf Twitter darüber aufgeregt.
Oh ja, das müssen wir auch.
Leute, das rewriten wir in Rust einfach demnächst.
Rust Rewrite.
By the way, meine Animation ist irgendwie ein bisschen broken, würde ich sagen.
wenn es bei null
Herzfrequenz immer noch pulsiert
ist irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt
wie dem auch sei
wo wollte ich jetzt eigentlich drauf raus
genau ich hab auf Twitter
wurde mir ein Post empfohlen
von irgendeinem Streamer
Streamerin glaube ich
und
die hat geschrieben
ich krieg das gar nicht mehr zusammen
dass sie das ganz
dass sie das irgendwie ganz schlimm findet,
wenn Streamer
fragen, wie es einem geht.
Weil das würde ja quasi so
den Personal
Space irgendwie verletzen.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
alter Mann, die Leute sind heute aber echt krass empfindlich.
AF-Programmer,
findest du auch
deinen Personal Space da irgendwie verletzt,
wenn ich dich jetzt fragen würde, wie geht's?
Oder der Feudia, der immer da ist.
Oder Nidwitch.
Oder die Leute, die immer am Schalten sind.
Ihr würdet euch auch krass
hier in euren persönlichen Dings
da eingeschränkt fühlen, wenn ich euch frage, wie es geht.
Kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Das ist ganz furchtbar schlimm.
MonkaS, Alter, wie geht's?
Wie kann man sowas fragen?
Lage? Ich denke Abmahnung erstmal.
So, ganz wichtig, Leute, jetzt.
Update.
Bam.
Oh, was ist hier los? Was wird hier?
Pipewire Local ist new und dann extra.
Ja, wie kann das denn eigentlich sein?
Warum ist mein Pipewire Local
Newer als
Wo hab ich das denn her
Warum ist das Local Newer
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn
Haben die das irgendwann mal vielleicht veröffentlicht
Und
Und wieder zurückgezogen
Installed.
Ja, guck mal. Die haben 1, 6, 8.
Das ist kein Supply Chain.
Das ist ja offizielles Repo.
Guck mal.
Guck mal. Wurde es zurückgezogen oder was?
Nö, hier gibt es
ganz normal.
8.
Guck mal, ich bin nicht der Einzige,
da sowas hier hat.
Seems like an issue in the
CatchyOS Extra Repo.
Okay, das ist irgendwie kaputt.
Ähm, wie?
Wie downgrade ich das denn?
Also ich könnte jetzt die einzelnen Packages
Stalkraden. Das ist ja aber wahrscheinlich
nicht Sinn und Zweck der
Übung. Könnte ich jetzt einfach
sagen, ich will jetzt lieber das
da. Aha. Guck.
Jetzt kaputt.
Wollen wir fragen mal
Chat-GPT, das weiß das bestimmt.
Fix.
Einfach random.
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ja, ich, das...
Ja.
Okay, das hat auch keine Ahnung.
Ja, kann ich jetzt einfach sagen...
Ja, was mache ich denn jetzt?
Kann ich das aninstallen?
Ne, aninstallen kann ich es nicht, weil mein Desktop drauf...
...rauf basiert.
Aber vielleicht kann ich...
...Pipe Pulse reinstallen.
Ne.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Wie haben die das...
Wie haben die das gefixt?
wie wie wie wie wie wie wie pulle ich
heckmann rieppel
reinstall all packages was
Äh
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich das will
Zeit die Cashew-Snapshot-Funktion zu testen
Ne, das ist schon 3 Wochen oder so
Ich hab das bisher immer komplett ignoriert
Ich glaub das
Das machen wir nicht
Kann man
Yes, latest Pipeboy affixed it.
Okay.
Was haben die jetzt gemacht?
Ja gut, whatever. Keine Ahnung.
Ich mach jetzt einfach so Upgrade.
Zack.
Irgendwann gibt es da auch mal neuere Versionen
Und ich krieg wieder das neuere
Aber das ist halt immer ein bisschen
Das ist halt ein bisschen dumm, ne
Also unter NixOS wäre das nicht passiert
Das ist richtig, also ich finde
Die Publishen ist immer ein bisschen problematisch
Die sollten lieber eine neue Version raushauen
Die halt im Zweifelsfall
Ein Rollback auf die alte macht, so quasi ein Git-Revert
Oder sowas unter der Haube
Weil sonst hast du halt immer diese Probleme
Fragen wir nochmal, komm die wissen das bestimmt nicht.
Repool older version.
Aha, guck mal da!
ChatGPT weiß Bescheid.
ChatGPT weiß Bescheid, das machen wir jetzt gleich.
Moin Max.
Und Max, wie geht's?
Ich hab gehört, das darf man im Stream nicht mehr fragen.
Das würde deinen Personal Space verletzen.
Fühlst du das auch so?
Okay
Okay, ich hab's gefixt, nice
So, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal was
Our Packages JetBrains Toolbox
Leute, kann ich mich trauen
JetBrains Toolbox zu upgraden
Oder wenn wir Supply Chain attackt
Okay, wir werden anscheinend nicht Supply Chain Attacked.
Werden wir Supply Chain Attacked?
Not found.
Geil.
Okay.
Wir tippen einfach mal drauf, wir werden nicht Supply Chain Attacked.
Chat, ich hab mir gestern, ich hab mir gestern überlegt,
dieses
Heartbeat-Ding, diesen
Heartbeat-Sensor, das Ausleseding, was
wir letztens in Go zusammengefuddelt haben,
wir werden das nochmal ordentlich
rewriten in Rust.
Weil alles in Rust
rewritet besser ist.
Ich habe letztens
ein Video drüber geguckt, wo einer
erklärt hat, wie toll das ist,
im Jahr
2026,
dass es so viele Open Source
Projekte gibt. Ich glaube, das war sogar ein Video
von Morpheus, was ich angefangen habe zu gucken.
Der hat
gesagt, das ist ganz toll
im Jahr 2026,
dass es so viele Open Source
Sachen und Libraries gibt, aber das ist
auch bedroht dadurch,
dass die Leute so wenig Geld verdienen
und einzelne
Maintainer sich darum kümmern müssen.
Vielleicht können wir das Video irgendwann mal gucken.
Zumindest hat er in dem Video gesagt, was halt super ist,
jetzt müssen sich die Leute nicht mehr mit grundlegendem Kram beschäftigen,
sondern können einfach eine fertige Library oder fertige Tools verwenden,
die es eben Open Source schon gibt.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, Moment, das machen vielleicht alle, außer die Rust-Rewriter.
Die Rust-Rewriter, die rewriten alles erstmal in Rust.
So nach dem Motto, Leute, ich will wissen, was in diesem Verzeichnis drin ist.
Was könnte ich jetzt machen? Ich könnte LS verwenden.
Ne, LS geht nicht.
LS muss erstmal rewritten werden in Rust, dass man hier LS machen kann.
So, habe ich jetzt rebooted? Ne, habe ich nicht.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal hier, ob es da Updates gibt.
Zack.
Check Updates.
Nix.
Okay, also nicht nix OS, sondern es gibt keine Updates.
Reboot.
So, jetzt müssen wir die Tastatur wieder umstöpseln.
Dadum, dadum.
Und dann können wir mal gucken, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Ich habe noch eine Frage an euch, Chat, gleich.
Aber da warte ich nochmal, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist und ein bisschen mehr da sind.
Muss ich euch was fragen?
Zur Karriereplanung?
Ich glaube, das Beste, was man machen kann, ist dafür den Twitch-Chat fragen, oder?
Glaube ich wirklich, also, higher Q-Move.
Twitch-Chat weiß das mit Sicherheit am besten.
Äh.
Ähm, chat.
So.
Splixer.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Huge.
Hugeste Subscription hier.
Eines der hugesten.
40 Jahre.
Pock.
Hochbaum ist es so laut.
Ah.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, warum das hier nicht stimmt.
Moment, Moment.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, warum der Sound so komisch ist
Ich hab das auf 50 stehen gehabt
Und nicht auf 30
Normalerweise hab ich den Sound immer auf 30 stehen
C++ ist crazy
Das, Chat
GTA 6 schon pre-ordert
Ne, wie gesagt, ich bin überhaupt kein GTA-Fan
Ich kann die große Faszination, die davon ausgeht
Ehrlich gesagt nicht nachvollziehen
noch nie.
Ja, also ich kenne GTA seit
GTA 1 und ich
hab's noch nie verstanden, was die
Leute so geil dran finden.
Witcher 3 gesehen, ja, das find ich cool.
Vor allem, weil's noch mal ein kostenloses
quasi HD-Update
gibt, was es doch eigentlich schon vor ein paar
Jahren gegeben hat, aber jetzt noch mal.
Hab ich nur in den
YouTube Vorschau Dingern
gesehen
Ich hab den Trailer gesehen zu
irgendeinem Dungeons & Dragons Game
Den Witcher Trailer
Äh was hab ich noch
Sonst ist mir zumindest nix
Im
im Kopf geblieben, was mich
irgendwie interessiert hat.
Ich habe aber eh nicht viel geguckt.
Nachdem mich die meisten neuen Releases
so die letzten Jahre über enttäuscht haben,
warte ich erstmal, bis der Kram da ist.
Ja, das finde ich auch mega.
Also ich habe
Witcher 3 irgendwann gekauft,
was weiß ich, wann das rausgekommen ist.
2013 oder so. Das ist ja schon
uralt.
Das Problem ist, ich kann nur was schauen, was mich selbst interessiert.
Die meisten Sachen interessieren mich halt nicht.
Was da an neuen Games rauskommt.
Aber das ist schon geil, ne?
Du hast ja bisher alle Updates von Witcher 3 kostenlos gekriegt, wenn du es irgendwann einmal gekauft hast.
Ah, zumindest auf Steam.
Wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, ist, was passiert, wenn du dir irgendwann mal Witcher 3 gekauft hast für die Konsole.
Das weiß ich nicht.
mit CD, ob du es dann auch kriegst.
Aber wenn du es dir auf Steam gekauft hast,
kriegst du die ganzen Updates kostenlos.
Das ist halt mega nice. Moin.
Das ist doch
Ragebait, oder?
Ist das Moneyboy da oben?
Chat?
Erkennt ihr das da oben?
Ist das
Ist das Money Boy im Icon?
Erkennt man nicht so richtig, aber ich kann da nicht ran zu.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Okay, C++ ist great.
Das kann er jetzt nicht alles lesen.
Ich will nur wissen, warum C++ great ist, okay?
Wobei, wenn ich das jetzt lese,
Chat, ich kann das erst lesen, wenn ich meinen Herzschlag-Sensor anhab, weil wir müssen ja wissen, wie sehr mich das aufregt.
Okay, wir kreppen da mal kurz mit dem Auge drüber, okay?
Warum C++ great ist.
Okay.
Warum ist es great?
Modern C++ is a different language.
Das stimmt, aber es ist immer noch eine beschissene Language.
Autotype-Deduction
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment
Ja, ja, ja, ich würde sagen
An sich
An sich ist Autotype-Deduction
Gut, das ist ein bisschen sowas, wie wenn ich
In C-Sharp schreiben kann, war I gleich 1
Oder, ups
Das ist ein bisschen, wie wenn ich in C-Sharp schreiben kann
War I gleich 1, kann man in C++
Auto I gleich einschreiben. Das ist gut.
Das Problem ist, wobei ehrlich gesagt
will ich das nicht, egal, das muss ich jetzt sagen.
Das Problem ist, dass es bei C++ wieder
zig verschiedene Varianten gibt, Variablen
zu initialisieren. Und
was ganz wirr ist, du kannst
ja mittlerweile
C++
Return-Type-Syntax.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie das...
Hier.
Du kannst mittlerweile diesen Scheiß
hier machen mit Return.
und dann musst du vorne Auto verwenden
und am Ende hat immer noch keine saune Ahnung, was da eigentlich passiert.
Ich meine, guckt euch das doch mal an.
WTF, was ist das denn hier schon wieder?
Also ich meine, das hier
muss man
Okay, siehst du, selbst
das hier meine ich, guck.
Das hier meine ich. Wo ist denn, bitteschön?
Ich hab's bis heute nicht verstanden, ja?
Wo ist denn bitte schön der Sinn davon, dass ich hier vorne Auto hinschreiben kann und da hinten sage ich return an an int, anstelle einfach das int hier vorne hinzuschreiben?
Also das ist wieder so ein komisches C++-Ding, wo man sich fragt, warum?
Das war doch perfectly fine, int hier vorne hinzuschreiben.
Alternativ kann man es übrigens bei der Sache auch komplett weglassen
Und das erkennt es automatisch
Keine Ahnung
Lambda Functions
Okay, C++ hat so ziemlich die hässlichsten
Okay, Python hat noch eklige Lambda Functions
Aber C++ hat so ziemlich die hässlichste
Lambda Functions Syntax
Die man sich überhaupt vorstellen kann
Standard Threading Library
Alter, mir fällt fast kaum eine beschissenere Implementierung von Threads, Async und Parallelism ein als in der C++ Standard Library.
WTF?
Ist das Ragebait der Artikel oder was?
Das ist Ragebait, oder?
The king has reclaimed his throne.
Ja klar, weil C++, was das eigentlich auch schon irgendwann mal King war.
Das kann auch nur Ragebait sein.
Was anderes kann ich mir nicht vorstellen bei dem Artikel.
So, haben wir jetzt alles geupdatet?
Ja, haben wir.
Okay, nice.
So, mal kurze 2 Minuten Entspannung nach C++ Rage.
Was geht da eigentlich gerade im Hintergrund ab?
Warum braucht mein Rechner so viel Speicher?
Äh, nicht so viel Speicher.
Ah, UpdateDB macht das.
Okay.
Das ist für Manpages, oder?
Ah, nee.
Locate.
Nutze ich auch eigentlich eh nicht.
Egal.
Aber vielleicht andere Tools bei mir.
Man darf das erstmal updaten hier.
Ist okay.
Ups.
Falsches Fenster.
Max, der Aufwachens-Stream vom Sonntag ist...
Ich habe meine IP geleakt.
Ach, die erste Stunde hast du nicht?
Hast du noch den Valomat?
Ist in der ersten Stunde der IP-Leak drin?
Das war, als ich irgendwas...
Den Valomat habe ich ziemlich am Ende gemacht.
Der ist, glaube ich, drin.
IP-Leak war irgendwann am Anfang.
Da wollte ich irgendwas zeigen.
Da wollte ich irgendwie...
Ja.
Wobei, keine Ahnung.
Weil gerade für den Valomat wäre es wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht, wenn wir das hochladen, falls mal wieder irgendeiner fragt, Max, und was willst du wählen?
Nächste Wahl.
Dann sage ich, guck dir das Video vom Valomat an.
Ja, ab und zu, aber nicht so oft.
Wobei, Max, weißt du, was wir machen?
Ich habe eine Idee.
Kannst du den Stream im Archiv aufheben
Aber ohne dass der Public zugänglich ist
Auf der Webseite
Oder generell einfach irgendwo hin kopieren
Dass ich mir vielleicht
Die
Was rausklippen kann
Okay, perfekt
Dann lass es erstmal so machen und nicht hochladen
Dann musst du jetzt nicht durchgucken, ob das da drin ist
So.
Chatkiss.
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Twitch Chat
plays Karriere Advice.
Sagt mir mal, was ihr machen würdet.
Hast du schon gesehen,
dass Nitta Daun genommen würde?
Ja, das war das erste, was ich heute im Stream
was ich heute im Stream
gesagt habe.
Und diese andere Alternativseite
auch leider.
ZG.
Fainstamp.
Leider.
Also Chat, hier.
Karriere-Advice. Twitch-Chat
plays Karriere-Kreisel-Krein.
Also, was würdet ihr
machen, wenn ihr die Auswahl hättet,
Zwischen. Also geht mal
davon aus, das Team, in dem ihr aktuell
arbeitet, auf der Arbeit, wird
aufgelöst.
Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen drastischer, als es ist,
aber das ist einfacher.
So.
Ne, Mask
darfst du beleidigen.
Du darfst du das plus Friedrich Merz
nicht beleidigen.
Oder Habeck, oder
wen sonst wen, dann
ist gleich verhaftet.
Also, überlegt, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid auf der Arbeit, euer Team, in dem ihr gerade seid, wird aufgelöst.
So, und jetzt habt ihr die Auswahl zwischen zwei Teams.
Das eine Team macht klassische Linux-Admin-Geschichten
Ja, mit ein bisschen Ansible, Bash-Geskripte, Linux-Gebastel
Die üblichen Verdächtigen, Hilfe, meine Festplatte läuft voll
Neues Serveraufbau und Ansible-Playbook dafür erstellen
Also quasi das, was man so als Linux-Admin macht
Ja, dann kümmert sich man kümmert sich darum, dass alle Server geupdatet werden. Man guckt, welche Basic Packages auf bis zu 4000 Linux System installiert sein sollen, sodass jeder einen T-Mux drauf hat, zum Beispiel solche Dinge.
Man guckt, dass die Vorgaben, die es da betrieblich gibt, auf allen Servern richtig ausgerollt werden.
Also so klassische Linux-Admin oder wie man das ja heutzutage neuer nennt, Linux-Engineer oder wie auch immer System-Engineer, keine Ahnung, Aufgabe.
Das ist das eine, wo ihr hingehen könntet.
So, und das andere Team kümmert sich darum, dass das ist rein Cloud-Gedöns und kümmert sich darum, was ganz Neues aufzubauen, nämlich eine interne Application-Hosting-Plattform auf Kubernetes-Basis.
Was damit gemeint ist, muss ich vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären.
Also, der Trend geht ja dahin, dass man sagt, dass die Leute, die die Anwendung bauen, sie letztendlich auch betreiben sollen.
Dass es ein Team gibt, wo die Anwendung entwickelt wird, plus auch ein paar Leute, die sich ein bisschen auskennen und die Anwendung betreiben sollen.
dass die natürlich nicht alle from scratch Kubernetes können oder sich da großartig mit auskennen oder irgendwelche Cloud-Sachen professionieren können mit Terraform, ist ja klar.
Das heißt, es soll jetzt eine interne Application-Hosting-Plattform aufgebaut werden, dass du quasi relativ easy deine selbstgebauten Anwendungen laufen lassen kannst.
Worauf du die laufen lassen kannst, ist zweitrangig.
Du sagst im Endeffekt nur noch, ich habe Anwendung dieses Container-Image auf diesem Port, brauche eine Datenbank, so nach dem Motto und unter der Haube macht dann diese Application-Hosting-Plattform Magic und sorgt dafür, dass deine Anwendung läuft.
ob das dann auf einer VM läuft, ob das dann bei Azure oder Google oder AWS läuft, im eigenen Rechenzentrum oder so,
ist egal, oder auf dem Kubernetes-Cluster, ist egal, du hast dann bloß noch ein ganz einfaches YAML-File,
wo du das definieren kannst und diese Application aus den Plattformen, übersetzt das dann anhand bestimmter Kriterien,
zum Beispiel, ey, wir haben noch ganz viel Quota bei Azure frei, lass das mal nach Azure schieben, weil es billiger ist, so nach dem Motto.
Ja, also die Auswahl habt ihr. Hat man das, andere Frage, hat man das verstanden, was ich versucht habe zu erklären mit dieser Application Hosting Plattform, ja. Also du bist dann zum Beispiel, du kannst dann damit, du bist ein Anwendungsentwickler, du hast jetzt, du hast eine Anwendung gebaut und du willst die Anwendung laufen lassen, ja.
Dann sagst, dann würdest du dann im Endeffekt eigentlich nur noch einen YAML anlegen.
Ich denke mir jetzt einfach mal was aus, ja.
Du würdest einen YAML anlegen, dann sagst du Stage, Prot, Dockerfile, Blub, keine Ahnung,
Need, DB, Postgres, sowas sagst du dann da drin, ja.
So, sowas sagst du dann drin und dann sagst du Port 3000 oder so, ja.
Irgendwie, ich habe mir jetzt einfach random irgendwas ausgedacht.
Im Endeffekt als Anwendungsentwickler sagst du dann einfach nur sowas und dann schmeißt du das diese Application Hosting Plattform hin und die macht dann daraus zum Beispiel, aha, wir haben hier noch Kapazitäten bei GKE, das heißt es kommt auf einen Google Kubernetes Cluster und dann wird alles darunter konfiguriert.
So, und ihr habt die Auswahl zwischen so einem klassischen Linux-Team oder einem neuen Team, was diese Application-Hosting-Plattform aufbaut.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, Chat, wo würdet ihr hingehen?
Achso, ich muss euch noch dazu sagen
Bei der Linux
Bei dieser
Klassischen, bei diesem klassischen Linux
Team, kennt ihr euren
Chef und ihr kennt euren Abteilungsleiter
Und ihr kennt auch einigen der Kollegen
Die dann bei euch im Team landen werden
Bei dieser neuen
Application Hosting Plattform
Kennt ihr weder offiziell zumindest den Chef
Noch den Abteilungsleiter
Noch kennt ihr wirklich gut
die Kollegen, die in dem Team landen.
Was würdet ihr machen?
Post-Champ.
Max Wechsel für mehr Geld?
Also, mehr Geld ist, glaube ich, bei keinem
bisher Thema gewesen von beiden.
Das mit dem Probieren ist schwierig.
Weil, wie gesagt, das alte Team wird ja aufgelöst.
In dem Beispiel.
Das hat mit Kryptocoins nichts zu tun.
Okay, ich kann euch...
Das ist schwierig, ne?
Ich bin da auch gerade am überlegen.
Ich tendiere tatsächlich dazu.
Ihr wisst ja, dass ich meine Karrieremachen-Ambitionen immer ein bisschen in Grenzen halte.
Und es mir hauptsächlich darum geht, dass mich das alles nicht zu sehr stresst.
Ich tendiere aktuell dazu, dahin zu gehen, wo ich die meisten Leute kenne.
Beziehungsweise wo ich den Chef kenne und weiß, dass der taugt.
unabhängig davon, was der beiden Sachen es dann letztendlich ist.
Also die Arbeit ist jetzt nicht unwichtig,
aber nachdem ich beides gerne machen würde,
ziehe ich das vor, wo ich die Leute kenne, den Chef kenne, den Abteilungsleiter kenne.
Weil ganz im Ernst, ja, es ist nicht unwichtig, was man macht,
aber die Rahmenbedingungen sind fast noch wichtiger.
Was bringt es dir, wenn du am Ende nur Leute im Team hast, die dich nerven?
Wobei, weiß ich nicht, ne?
Also, ich kenne die ja zum größten Teil da gar nicht.
Aber wenn man dann im Endeffekt mit irgendwelchen Leuten im Team landet,
die einen nur nerven,
Chef hat, den man nicht kennt, sich mit dem vielleicht nicht versteht,
weiß man nicht,
oder irgendeinen neuen Abteilungsleiter kriegt,
der dann irgendwie komische Dinger macht.
Also, ja.
Also, dann mache ich vielleicht lieber
bisschen weniger flashy Zeugs,
Ja, klassisches Linux-Krempel.
Wirklich mit abgedrehtem Kram ausleben kann ich mich ja hier im Stream.
Da machen wir ja Zeug, das kann ich auf der Arbeit garantiert nicht machen.
Auf der Arbeit muss ich keine Herzschlag-Sensoren auslösen, äh, auslesen oder sowas.
Ja, man weiß es halt nicht. Man weiß es nicht.
Ja doch, man kann
Also, ich hab ja schon ein bisschen nachgeforscht, ja
Man kann ein bisschen was rausfinden
Also ich weiß
Ich weiß bisher von den Kollegen, die ich kriege
Dass die wohl ganz okay sind
Aber ich kenn die nicht
Ist ja auch so
Ist auch so
Also was ich bisher rausgekriegt hab, der neue Chef
Der ist wohl ganz okay
Ich hab mit dem aber nichts zu tun gehabt
Und die Kollegen kenn ich nicht, wirklich
Die da hingehen
Müssten wohl aber auch ganz okay sein.
Abteilungsleiter, keine Ahnung.
Wer das wird, beziehungsweise wie der die ist.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, ne?
Das Ding ist halt,
okay, dann sag ich jetzt mal, wie es ist,
das Ding ist halt, ich tendiere
eindeutig dazu,
ich tendiere
tatsächlich eindeutig dazu,
ich gehe dahin, wo ich die Leute kenne,
wo ich den Chef kenne und weiß, dass es taugt,
die Arbeit ist ja auch nicht schlecht, was man da macht,
ja, hat man auch einige Möglichkeiten,
im Prinzip das, was ich jetzt auch mache,
ja, plus ein bisschen weniger Cloud-Gedöns,
meinetwegen,
Ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, aber dafür weiß ich, dass das Arbeitsklima nicht schlecht ist, der Chef gut ist und das, was man macht, auch nicht übel ist.
Also da weiß man einfach, was man hat. Auf der anderen Seite, und jetzt zum Thema Karrierekreise-Crime, auf der anderen Seite habe ich gehört, dass die Schwierigkeiten haben, das Team voll zu bekommen für diese interne App-Hosting-Plattform.
weil die zu wenig leute haben die sich mit kubernetes kubernetes betrieb in der cloud
und mit container betrieb auskennen und mir wird versucht das schmackhaft zu machen dass
ich da hingehe weil sie nicht genug leute mit know how haben und ich halt laut meinem chef
einer der wenigen in der firma bin der sich damit so gut auskennt dass er damit machen könnte
Vielleicht hätte ich da die Chance zu sagen
Ja, okay
Aber dann
Könnt ihr mich ja eine Stufe hochstufen
Weil dann bin ich ja so krasser Know-how-Träger
Dass ihr mich
Gehaltsmäßig noch eine Stufe hochstufen könnt
Die Möglichkeit hätte ich dann vielleicht
Aber die Frage ist
Und das ist das, worauf meine ganze Sache
hier eigentlich abzielt. Die Frage ist,
ist es das wert?
Weil bei der anderen Sache hätte ich halt
Leute, die ich kenne, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe,
Chef, der super ist, Abteilungsleiter,
der super ist, da weiß ich halt, was abgeht.
Bei dem anderen
könnte es halt echt sein, dass es
ein Griff, also glaube ich nicht
wirklich, aber es könnte sein,
dass es ein Griff ins Klo wird. Man weiß es
halt nicht. Ich kenne die Leute nicht, ich kenne den Chef nicht,
ich kenne den Abteilungsleiter nicht.
Welche Arbeit willst du eher machen?
Eigentlich würde ich beides gerne machen.
Ich würde gerne Cloud-Gedöns
basteln. Vor allem kann man da halt
auch ein bisschen mehr Proggers-Stells machen.
Ich würde aber auch weiterhin gerne nebenbei
noch klassisches Linux-Zeug machen, weil ich bin ja auch
gerne Linux-Bastler.
Ich kann nicht zurück, das Team wird aufgelöst.
Das jetzige Team.
Also eigentlich würde ich beides gerne machen.
Ich kann euch gar nicht sagen.
Also ja, von der Technik her ist das mit den Containern sicherlich spannender.
Da habe ich halt meine Bedenken, dass man den ganzen Tag YAML Engineering macht.
Gibt es dann auch keine Blockchain mehr?
Doch, doch, die gibt es noch.
Die gibt's noch. Die landet dann wahrscheinlich auch letztendlich bei diesem Team.
Das würde ich dann wahrscheinlich mitnehmen.
Ja, das kann man so nicht sagen.
Wenn du nur den ganzen Tag YAML-Files und Terraform machst, da hast du auch keinen Bock drauf.
Das habe ich ein paar Wochen mal machen müssen.
Da habe ich wirklich YAML-Engineert von morgens bis abends und Terraform-Krams gemacht.
So geil ist das auch nicht.
Also ab und zu ist mal so der Klassiker
Linux Terminal und da ein bisschen was
Rumfuddeln
Auch nicht schlecht
Ne, das geht nicht
Also ich tendiere, ich mach Linux Sachen
Du hast die Idee, okay
Let's go
Jetzt bin ich gespannt
Jetzt kommt's
PostChamp.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Einfach AI fragen.
Wenn du irgendwo hingehst, fordere ein Linux-Arbeits-PC.
Sehr gute Idee.
Habe ich tatsächlich schon gemacht.
Aber kein PC.
PC, also Hardware, Linux, drauf installieren auf Hardware gibt es bei uns nicht.
das muss das Linux, das muss das
auditierte Windows Notebook sein
aber was ich gemacht habe ist
habe ich doch letztens schon erzählt
wir haben jetzt die Möglichkeit neue VMs zu bekommen
mit Grafikkarten drin und allem
die habe ich jetzt beantragt
wie ich gescheit drauf zugreife weiß ich
noch nicht genau
vielleicht kann ich
die dazu überreden
dass man dort
auf dem Client, wie heißt das?
Moonlight?
Sunshine?
Installieren kann
für
möglichst Latency,
niedrige Latency
Bedienung.
Da müssten die Sunshine-Client
oder Moonlight-Client, wie auch immer, ihr wisst
vielleicht, was ich meine, dieses
Linux-Game-Streaming-Ding,
wo man auch seinen Desktop mit streamen kann.
Das könnten die auf dem Desktop installieren.
Ja, aber ich hab schon neue
VR mit Grafikkarte beantragt
Gibt es, gibt es doch
Gibt es
Hab ich auch auf GitHub sogar schon gesehen
Doch, doch, gibt's
Du meinst, dass man
Du meinst den Host oder was
Auf Android
Aber, aber
Clients gibt's für Android
Ist das nicht Apollo oder so?
Nee, nee, du kannst
damit auch dein Desktop streamen.
Nee, Host wäre gut.
Das, das, ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht geben das die Android-APIs nicht her.
Mach dich als Berater
selbstständig für beide Teams.
Das wäre gut.
Da kann die Firma ein bisschen Pepo-Burn-Money machen,
indem sie es an mich überweisen.
So, Chat, geh rein, gucken wir mal.
Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht wirklich schlauer, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber ich glaube, ich bleib dabei.
Ich mach weiter Linux-Stells.
Da weiß ich wenigstens, wer die Kollegen sind, wer der Chef ist, wer der Abteilungsleiter ist.
Und die sind alle super.
Okay.
So.
Trend.
Und was trendet denn auf GitHub diese Woche so Schönes?
Lasst uns mal gucken.
Bestimmt wieder AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Wisst ihr, was ich machen würde?
Ich würde das annehmen.
Also mal angenommen, irgendjemand sagt, Max, willst du Minister für Digitales und Staatsmodernisierung werden?
Wisst ihr, was ich dann machen würde?
Dann würde ich sagen, ja, mache ich.
Und nächsten Tag trete ich zurück.
Free Renten-Hack.
Wenn du das einmal warst, kriegst du, glaube ich, dicke Geld.
Easy.
Das ist dreist, ja und?
Interessiert das in der Politik irgendjemand anderen,
ob das dreist ist?
Du musst mindestens 3,5 Jahre...
Was, wirklich?
Scheiße.
Muss man wirklich eine gewisse...
Okay, Moment, Moment, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Wie lange muss man Minister sein, damit man Rente bekommt?
Gibt es keine Einvergänglichkeit?
Welches Amt?
Bundesminister für Deutschland Digitales.
Für einen Bundesminister gilt nach dem Bundesministerium mindestens vier Jahre Mitglied der Bundes...
Ach, scheiße, Alter.
Oh, das ist ja dumm.
Das ist ja dumm, dass das nicht geht.
Also, für mich wäre das dumm.
Insgesamt finde ich gut, dass das nicht geht.
Wir haben das gepatcht.
Ja, ja, ja.
Siehste?
Okay, dann würde ich das nicht machen.
Dann würde ich das nicht machen.
Den Stress würde ich mir nicht geben.
Vor allem kannst du eh nicht das umsetzen, was du willst
Weil dir irgendwelche Leute auf den Sack gehen
So
Also, guck mal, was auf GitHub trennt
Oh
Oh, Leute, ich muss noch mal was trinken, kurz
So
Also, was trendet denn diese Woche so auf GitHub?
Zeigst du mal hier.
AI.
Warum das so beliebt ist? Keine Ahnung.
Letztendlich ist das ein Art-Schnittungs-Mit-Custom-Installer-Setup-Skript.
Keine Ahnung, warum das so beliebt ist. Verstehe ich nicht.
Ist das eigentlich Wayland-based mittlerweile?
Oder war das schon Wayland-based?
Interessiert mich eh nicht.
Werde ich nicht ausprobieren.
AI.
Logitech written in Rust.
Da kann man unter Linux seine Logitech-Geräte logitechen.
Ich dachte, da gibt es ein Screenshot oder sowas.
Openlogi.org
Ach hier.
Ah ja.
Okay, es ist
Es ist quasi so eine
So eine Geschichte hier
Sowas ähnliches
Wie das hier
Nur in
Nur für Linux
Aber Blazingly Fast written in Rust
Die meiste Software ist doch sowieso noch
Total langsam auf Wayland
Nee, warum?
Also Wayland hat mit Sicherheit seine Probleme
Gerade das vieles was unter X
ging, auch wenn es nicht schön war,
nicht funktioniert.
Diese ganze
Remote-Desktop-Geschichte
oder Anwendung Remote oder so, das ist halt unter Wayland.
Abfuck.
Funktioniert richtig.
Aber wenn du es native
verwendest, ja, also wenn du...
Das hier ist ja auch Wayland, jetzt letztendlich.
Das hier ist KDE mit Wayland.
Da ist nichts langsam.
Guck mal, und vor allem hast du noch
Hast du richtig gute Sachen, du hast das allerwichtigste Feature
Hier, ein GPU-beschleunigtes
Wobbly Windows, Leute
Seht ihr das?
Ein GPU-beschleunigtes Wobbly Windows, also
Das ist das Beste
Da ist nix langsam
Das ist bei euch ein bisschen lag
Das liegt daran, dass ihr nur mit 48 FPS
Dass nur mit 48 FPS gestreamt wird
Bei mir sind es 240 FPS
Lokal, das ist ein butterweiches
Wobbly Windows hier
Da ist nix langsam
Guck mal, ihr seht ja, das macht sogar kaum CPU-Last hier
Nö, nö
Also das würde ich nicht sagen
Du hast ein paar Dinger, die nicht richtig funktionieren unter Wayland, ja
Aber die meisten Sachen, die funktionieren, die funktionieren auch ziemlich schnell
Ah, dass du Probleme mit Clipboard hast, mit Automatisierung, mit Remote und so
Ah, das gibt's viele Probleme in Wayland
Aber wenn's geht, dann geht's, ja
Ja, Sway, ganz ehrlich, das Problem bei Wayland ist, dass Wayland kein X-Server in dem Sinne ist, wo alle Desktops oben drauf aufsetzen und unter der Haube alle den gleichen X-Server benutzen.
Bei Wayland ist es ja so, Sway implementiert das selbst, KDE implementiert das selbst, Hyperland, Niri implementieren das selbst.
Das heißt, du hast ganz viele unterschiedliche Features, die unterschiedlich implementiert sind und unterschiedlich unterstützt werden.
Das heißt, nur weil was unter KDE gut funktioniert, heißt das nicht, dass es unter Sway funktioniert.
Und umgedreht.
Deswegen bin ich ja mittlerweile auch auf KDE, weil man generell sagen kann, die großen Desktops haben, was Wayland-Feature-Abdeckung angeht, haben es noch am besten.
Gnome kannst du komplett vergessen
Gnome macht ihre eigenen Gnome-Dinge
Und außerdem ist Gnome so ein beschissener Desktop
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht leiden
So, gucken wir weiter
AI
Ein C++ Testing Framework, MonkaS
Toll
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an
Wie, ob, ob, Chat
Ich gucke mir das nicht an, weil mich Testing
In C++ interessiert
Ihr wisst ja, Testing brauchen wir prinzipiell nicht, weil alles First-Drive funktioniert und was soll man dann da testen.
Aber mich interessiert, ob ein Testing-Framework für C++ gut leserlich ist oder nicht.
Was meint ihr, Chat? Sieht das ordentlich aus oder sieht das C++-Style super hässlich aus?
Ich meine, Testing-Frameworks haben durchaus das Potenzial, dass die auch in C++ ordentlich aussehen können.
Ja, ich meine, was brauchst du denn da?
Du brauchst dann irgendwie sowas hier, irgendwie Function, was weiß ich, Check if return ist 0 oder sowas, ja.
Oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Expect, bla bla, also das kann nicht so kompliziert sein.
Aber gucken wir mal, wie das aussieht, Example.
So, also wenn es in einem GTA-Projekt schon mal keine Example gibt, das ist immer ein bisschen cringe.
Okay, Cookbook.
Alter, sieht das scheiße aus.
Alter, das sieht ja richtig räulich aus.
Gibt's da vielleicht auch mal irgendwie...
Wisst ihr, ich will einfach...
Samples.
Okay, Samples.
Sample 1.
Äh.
Was hat das jetzt mit Testing zu...
Achso.
Sample 1 Unit Test CC.
Hier muss ich gucken.
Oh.
Das sind alles irgendwelche Makros, oder?
Ich meine, es sieht halt...
Es sieht halt letztendlich aus, wie mehr oder weniger jedes Testing Framework aussieht.
Es sieht halt aus, mehr oder weniger, wie jedes Testing Framework aussieht, halt nur ein bisschen hässlicher, weil es C++ ist.
Das geht schon, das geht schon klar.
Das geht schon klar.
Machen wir mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen advancedere Samples.
Und mal, wie hässlich das da aussieht.
Okay, hier wird es schon ekliger, Leute.
Hier wird es schon ekliger.
Okay, man hat schon mal keine Ahnung,
was hier eigentlich getestet wird.
Absolut kein blassen Schimmer,
was hier getestet wird gerade.
Was?
Okay, das kann man lesen, ja.
Ah ja gut, es sieht halt aus wie das
Explebisch-Testing-Framework, nur ein bisschen hässlich, weil es
C++ ist.
Es sieht auch nach viel Makro-
Rahmen aus. Das ist aber schon mal...
Aber allein schon, weil es C++ ist,
sieht es schon mal ekliger aus, als in den
meisten anderen Sprachen. Okay,
lasst uns mal gucken. Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier? Language.
Rust!
Was trendet denn in Rust?
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich gefunden habe?
Rust NUSB.
Hier, guckt mal.
A new pure Rust library for cross-platform low-level access to USB devices.
Damit können wir den Heartbeat-Sensor programmieren in Rust.
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
In den nächsten Tagen mal oder heute, keine Ahnung.
Da wird, wird, ähm,
das wird hier in Rust
rewritten.
Und das Schöne ist, dadurch, dass es keine
LibUSB-Bindings braucht, kann man ein
Self-Contained Binary kompilieren,
was dann einfach läuft, halt auf Linux.
Ja, auf Windows.
Who cares?
So, also.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Was trennt er denn in Rust? OpenLogic, das hatten wir
gerade schon. Wieder ein bisschen Progress-Stellens.
Ja, aber Rust
Blazingly fast
Moment, warum habe ich das Seagate immer noch drin?
Moment, oh, oh, oh
Warum läuft da komisches Zeug, was nicht mal ein Stream ist?
Ah, okay
Ah, das habe ich wieder raus, sehr gut
Das hat mal, nur dass sich keiner hier wundert,
das hat mal irgendjemand,
hat das im Chat als Antwort geschrieben auf irgendwas.
Du kannst übrigens, Schwurbel kannst du auch löschen.
Das ist aus dem Kontext, das versteht keiner mehr.
Das Kommentar ist drei Jahre alt gewesen, was einer gepostet hat.
Kannst du auch löschen.
Ähm, Superkeck Alu, kannst du auch löschen.
Und, ähm, ja.
Also Ausrufezeichen Schwurbel.
Das schon, so.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht von mir.
Das hat mal irgendjemand im Chat geschrieben, glaube ich, auf das, was ich gesagt habe.
Weiß ich nicht, was der macht.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, wo das herkam.
Was war denn da das Thema, dass der das da drauf geschrieben hat?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
M95?
Geht es da um
Sniper in Call of Duty oder was?
Ein M95 ist doch
So ein Sniper, oder?
Ach ne
Aber das kannst du auch löschen
Weil ganz ehrlich, die Zusammenhang checkt ja keiner mehr
Nicht, dass die Leute noch denken, ich würde das sagen.
Das ist es ja nicht.
Das sind irgendwelche sinnlosen Comments, die Leute mal im Chat gepostet haben.
Lösch das auch nochmal weg.
Moment, du hast tatsächlich dazu einen...
Moment.
Windows in der Cloud ausprobieren? MonkaS?
Also, das ist deine ganze Argumentation.
Hahaha.
Okay, das kommt von YouTube.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
was er...
Was will er? Was wollte er denn hier überhaupt?
Okay, okay, was?
Was?
Ach du Scheiße, das ist ja halber
Roman, den der Typ geschrieben hat
damals, Alter.
Oh Gott.
Das war vor KI.
Das war weit vor KI.
Was ist das hier?
Da haben die Leute diese Texte noch selbst geschrieben.
Ja, Max, hau den Ausrufezeichen M95 auch mal weg.
Du machst der Mikrocontroller-Forum-User.
Ja, stimmt.
Nur, dass die dir schreiben,
dass du zu dumm bist für 8-Bit-Assembler-Programmieren
und dass das einzig Wahre ist, weil alles andere zu kompliziert ist.
Und das haben sie 1975 auch gemacht.
Das ist Mikrocontroller-Forum.
Ups.
Ja, wir haben auf der Arbeit auch, Leute,
das fuckt mich immer ab.
Da machst du dir Gedanken, fragst die was
und die pasten dir dann einfach die Antwort
von der KI zurück.
Als hätte ich nicht selbst schon mal KI gefragt, ja?
Denken die Leute, ich bin zu dumm, was in KI zu pasten,
oder was?
Okay, lasst uns mal gucken, was trendet denn in Rust.
Das hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon, hatten wir schon.
Production-Grade Rust Native Trading Engine.
Leute, Stonks.
Ja, Mietproxy nennt man das.
Das habe ich auch letztens irgendwo gelesen.
Stonks.
Einfach mal KI-Build.
Crypto-Trading-Strongs, glaube ich.
Max, können wir statt GitHub nicht die Top-Microcontroller...
Doch, aber die haben leider kein Top-Ranking irgendwie.
Da müssen wir erst mal Darkreader anmachen, sonst geht das nicht.
High Performance JavaScript Tools.
Das kennen wir auch schon.
Vault Worden.
Git Oxide.
Das ist...
Git re-implemented in Rust.
Das ist bestimmt eine Library,
dass ich Git-Repos aus Rust verwenden kann, oder?
Alles andere macht ja keinen Sinn.
Warum?
Na gut, ich wollte gerade sagen,
warum sollte man Git in Rust re-implementen,
aber es wird alles in Rust re-implemented?
Aber als Library macht es natürlich Sinn.
GPUI-Component.
Rust GUI-Components for building fantastic cross-platform applications using GPUI.
Mal gucken, wie gut das aussieht.
Schauen wir mal.
Ach, das hatten wir doch schon mal.
Das sieht super weirdchamp aus.
A friendly language
for scalable
Ru-Vektor.
AI.
Turbo Repo AI.
Also das ist relativ unspektakulär.
Was machen denn die Leute
in Go heute?
Proxy-Stells, glaube ich.
AI.
Abzut, keine Ahnung, aber...
Wahrscheinlich AI.
Wahrscheinlich auch...
AI.
Terminal Music Player
Inspired by Winamp
Sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Winamp
Winamp
Und wie war das?
Win
Winamp Llamas S
Das da
Wenn es wirklich die Lange ist,
Beste.
Würde ich heute noch verwenden, wenn ich lokal Musik abspielen würde.
Okay, nicht so spannend.
Was hier drin ist.
Ihr könnt euch noch zwei Sprachen aussuchen, wo wir uns die Trends angucken.
Während ihr euch was aussucht, wir machen jetzt das, was der RF-Programmer vorgeschlagen hat.
Ich guck mal schnell drüber, ob ich euch nochmal wieder demonstrieren kann, dass das das schlimmste Forum ist aller Zeiten.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Also das Mikrocontroller-Forum ist berühmt-berüchtigt dafür, dass da sehr viele Deppen unterwegs sind.
Also mal angenommen, ihr habt euch ein ESP32 gekauft, so ein Einsteigerboard, irgendwas, NodeMCU, ihr habt euch irgendwie so ein Einsteiger, geht mal davon aus, alter, was ist mit euch los, EatsDelivery.
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt euch so ein Microcontroller-Einsteiger-Bot gekauft mit USB-Anschluss und allem.
Ja, ihr habt da ein bisschen mit dem eingebauten Micro-Python rumgebastelt.
Ihr wollt ein paar LEDs blinken lassen und jetzt habt ihr ein Problem.
Zum Beispiel, dass eure LED nicht blinkt.
Ja, ihr seid Einsteiger, ihr habt Beispielcode euch angeguckt, ein bisschen KI gefragt und ihr kommt einfach nicht dahinter, warum eure LED nicht blinkt.
Und dann denkt ihr euch, ich google mal danach und dann findet ihr das Mikrocontroller-Forum.
Und dann macht ihr da einen Post.
Dann müsst ihr euch erstmal anhören, dass ESP32 wahrscheinlich dafür eine scheiß Einstiegsboard ist.
Dass MicroPython eh kompletter Schrott ist.
Dass nur 8-Bit-Assembler wie 1975 gut ist.
Dass ihr die LED wohlmöglich ohne Widerstand angeschlossen habt und deswegen euer Haus gleich einstürzt.
dass ihr allgemein überhaupt, weil ihr so dumm seid, das eigentlich gar nicht machen solltet,
weil wer das nicht first try perfekt hinbekommt, ist einfach zu dumm
und sollte am besten direkt das alles aufs Fenster schmeißen.
So, das ist so ungefähr die Standardantworten, die ihr im Microcontroller-Forum bekommt.
Schauen wir mal. Schauen wir mal, ob wir da ein schönes Beispiel.
Schönes Beispiel für finden
Stackoverflow auf Deutsch
Okay, hilfreich
Hilfreich
Was ist da los, warum ist das hilfreich
WTF
Wie jetzt
Warum ist das hilfreich gewesen
Was ist da los
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein
Warum ist der Pause hilfreich
Okay Schaltplan
Da wird geflamed
Geht schon gut los
Okay jetzt schauen wir mal
Ob das wirklich so schlimm ist
Ich finde das sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus
Sieht aus wie ich mir so ein Schaltplan
Vorstellen würde
Ohne jetzt der große Checker zu sein, aber
Es ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen random verteilt, ja
Das bin doch nicht ich, WTF
Ja, das sind wieder sehr hilfreiche
Posts gewesen.
Frage zu Sensoren.
Ah, das ist bestimmt auch toll.
Man muss dann meistens ein bisschen
runterscrollen, bis es dann
Ah, hier sind sie schon.
Hier sind sie schon wieder am diskutieren, ja.
Also, wer mal wirklich
richtig eklige, nervige Diskussionen
lesen will,
dann
Microcontroller-Forum.
Das ist richtig nett, Geforum.
Okay, wir fragen mal.
Top 10 der schlimmsten Posts oder Threads im Mikrocontroller.net Forum.
Ah ja, Chat-GPT kann das nicht.
Okay, gucken wir nochmal kurz, was in Go trendet.
Warten wir, warten wir, warten wir.
Nichts Spannendes hatten wir auch schon.
Wobei, jetzt haben wir schon durchgeguckt.
total aus. Das will ich ja die ganze
Zeit schon mal ausprobieren, Leute.
Das ist
eine Linux-Distribution, die nichts anderes
macht, als Kubernetes zu runnen.
Gibt's auf Codeberg?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass es da so viele Sachen
gibt. Gibt es Codeberg
Trending?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Gibt es nicht
Explore
Was?
Explore Sword by
Most Stars
Bam
Was sind die Repos mit den meisten Sternen?
Schauen wir mal hin
Bin mal gespannt
Sick, na klar, was sonst
Ähm, okay
Portgeo selber
Foot Terminal
Wayland Terminal Emulator.
Da habe ich noch gar nicht so genau gecheckt,
was davon jetzt irgendwie der Vorteil sein soll,
ehrlich gesagt.
Features. Fast.
Lightweight. Wayland Native.
DE-Agnostic. Server Demon Mode.
Kann es denn...
Kann es denn Tabs und Splits
und so?
Nee, oder?
Ein Terminal ohne Splits
kann ich nicht mehr benutzen.
Und bevor jetzt einer kommt, Chatge,
ich weiß genau, ich weiß genau, dass der erste
von euch jetzt schon im Chat da sitzt,
ja, dann benutzt doch Temux.
Temux ist
inferior gegen Terminal Splits,
weil, guckt mal hier, Temux, Split.
Machen wir mal Temux, Split.
So, bla.
So, jetzt wollt ihr, ihr wollt
diese Zeile hier markieren, ne?
Ihr wollt diese Zeile markieren.
Bam.
Ihr markiert beides mit.
Seht ihr das?
Weil Temux weiß halt nicht,
beziehungsweise das Terminal weiß halt nicht,
dass Temux hier einen Split hat.
Guckt, ihr wollt diese Zeile markieren.
Bam.
Er markiert die komplette Zeile,
weil er halt nicht weiß,
dass da ein Split drin ist.
Wohingegen,
Splitten mit dem Terminal,
kein Problem.
Das Terminal weiß,
dass hier ein Split ist.
Ja, also allein schon aus dem Grund
ist es viel angenehmer,
mit dem Terminal Splits zu arbeiten,
als mit Temux Splits.
Das zweite ist,
wenn ihr SSH verwendet, ja?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr macht T-Mox, dann macht ihr SSH.
Oh, Maus-Mode in T-Mox ist richtig eklig.
Da kannst du dann nicht gescheit scrollen im Terminal.
Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz eklig.
Und wenn du mehrere T-Mox-Tabs benutzt,
mehrere Tabs, das geht, aber manchmal willst du es ja gesplittert haben.
ssh wir starten jetzt mal ssh machen wir macht jetzt hier ssh local house so seit
der per se sind wir per ssh drauf und jetzt habt ihr tmux in tmux
ich habe tmux maus mod ausprobiert tmux maus mod ist genauso wie celli
celli j maus mod das ist das ist eklig das fühlt sich nicht gut an
Ja, und jetzt habt ihr T-Mux in T-Mux.
Das heißt, jetzt müsst ihr STRG-B
B drücken, beispielsweise.
Das klappt schon gar nicht mehr.
Das ist halt Mist.
Deswegen benutze ich nur noch Tabs und Splits
in meinem lokalen Terminal.
Und per SSH halt
nur noch auf dem Server dann.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich kann ja nicht mehr genau sagen,
was mich gestört hat am T-Mux-Maus-Mode.
Gucken wir mal.
Wie schaltet man das ein?
Doppelpunkt, ne, B, Doppelpunkt, Set, Maus oder wie?
Maus?
Temux Enable Maus Mode.
Set, G, Maus, On.
Okay.
So, jetzt haben wir hier die Maus Mode.
Boah.
Alter, wie das rumbackt.
Guck mal, das richtige...
Oh, ne, das kann ich nicht.
Das ist laggy. Das ist richtig laggy auch schon.
Guck mal, ich klicke jetzt
und eine Sekunde später markiert das erst.
Das ist ganz...
Das ist ganz, ganz eklig.
Und wo ich mir auch, ehrlich gesagt,
nicht sicher bin,
findest du es eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt so mache...
Findest du es denn,
wenn ich jetzt so mache
und dann hier hochscrolle,
ist dann alles
da.
Ja, okay, das funzt zumindest
immerhin, ja.
Also Maus-Mode,
das kann ich nicht haben. Da kommt nämlich
dazu, wenn du Maus-Mode anhast,
jetzt hast du Maus-Mode dann auch in
Wim an und
ne, ne, ne.
Ganz ehrlich, Native Splits
beste. Warum auch nicht?
Ja, solange
das geht.
Ist das ja okay. Native Splits
und auf dem Server immer T-Mux. Fertig.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Kenn ich nicht. Gadget Bridge.
Ein SIG.
Kurs.
LibreWolf.
Was ist LibreWolf?
Ist das, ist das, ist das, ähm, dieser, so ein E-Book-Reader?
Oder auch nicht.
Es wäre cool, wenn da vielleicht mal ein Satz zu stehen würde, was LibreWolf ist.
CacheOS Browser Settings. Cache Browser? Warum hat denn die man einen eigenen Browser macht überhaupt keinen Sinn?
Keine Ahnung was das ist. Strudel!
Ja jetzt haben wir die wichtigsten Sachen eigentlich schon durch.
App finder and fuzzy finder for Wayland.
Inspired by Rufin D-Menü.
Gut, ich benutze einfach den in KDE eingebauten mittlerweile.
Was soll das sein?
Okay, whatever.
App-Launcher.
Okay, das ist wirklich sowas wie
Rufi, ja.
Alter, MonkaS.
Also viel gab es
jetzt da nicht zu gucken.
Bin mal gespannt,
was KDE jetzt baut für die
EFESTAP Netzlaufwerk UI Geschichte.
Was meinst du?
Was ist da neu?
Was habe ich verpasst?
Was will KDE da bauen?
So, dann hätten wir das.
Also eine Sprache können wir uns ankommen.
Komm, wir gucken mal was.
Lass mal kurz hier random scrollen, okay?
Wir gucken jetzt was.
Okay, aber C Sharp ist langweilig.
Kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
C Sharp ist immer der gleiche Krempel.
Und
nichts Neues.
Das ist langweilig.
immer der gleiche Krempel.
Okay, das kenne ich tatsächlich noch nicht.
Aspire?
Ich habe bis heute,
Microsoft hat ja da super krass die Werbetrommel
mal gerührt für, ich habe bis heute
legit immer noch keine Ahnung,
was Aspire eigentlich genau sein soll.
Dass man Netzlaufwerke in einer UI konfigurieren
kann, nicht wie gerade bei Dolphin und Hemdtyp.
Ach.
Netzlaufwerke mounten?
Oder Netzlaufwerke bereitstellen?
Oh, ja. Das ist gut. Das kommt mal gleich.
Also ein ordentliches Samba-UI
wäre echt nicht verkehrt, weil Samba-Config
ist immer Pains-Champ.
Und das hat man.
Wheel Wizard.
Was soll denn das sein?
Okay.
Visual Basic.
Da gibt es VBA.
Gibt es gar nicht.
Oh doch, VBA.
VBA.
Bam.
Trennt er überhaupt was?
Oh, VBA trennt nichts.
Fast Open Source Modern Image Viewer.
Okay, da sieht tatsächlich modern aus.
Moment, das kostet sogar was.
WTF, was?
Warum brauche ich ein Abo?
Warum brauche ich ein Abo für einen Image Viewer?
Was zur Hölle?
Aber warum?
Warum?
Was?
Oh.
Okay, wir brauchen noch
eine Sprache, die wir nachgucken können
heute, weil VBA
gab es nichts. Wir gucken
jetzt, okay, was, was?
Wir gucken definitiv nicht C++.
Elixier.
Damit habe ich ja noch
nie was gemacht. Das ist irgendein Frontend
gedönst, ne? Damit habe ich ja noch nie
was gemacht.
Tesla made Fire Zone?
Symphonie?
Da muss ich mal
mir ein Example angucken.
Lang Example.
Wie sieht denn Elixier aus?
Ich will eigentlich nur mal ein paar...
Äh, nein.
Das sieht ein bisschen...
Das hat sogar ein bisschen was von Ruby.
Wir können doch hier mal reingucken, wie Elixier-Code aussieht.
ja keine ahnung mqtt publisher elixier es hat ein ganz ganz kleines bisschen was von
ruby mit diesen eindrückungen und dem end davon end es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ruby
Wobei, für meinen Geschmack hat es ein bisschen zu viele Klammern schon wieder.
Das sieht doch eklig aus.
Also, da habe ich noch nie was mitgemacht, noch nie was gesehen von.
Und ich glaube auch noch nie was benutzt.
Postgres changes via Websocket
What?
Erstmal jede Postgres Änderung
Per Websocket schicken
Excellent
Phoenix Framework
Okay wie sieht da ein
Exempel aus
Haben wir noch ein Example?
Gibt nichts.
Example.
Get started.
Gibt kein Example.
Ja.
Auf der Startseite war eins.
Ist nicht gesehen.
Ach, hier unten.
Ja, jetzt schaue ich weiter, scrollen.
Dev module, use Phoenix, live view, render.
Ach, man macht da im...
Läuft das jetzt serverseitig oder kleinseitig?
Oder ist das so eine Hydration-Geschichte?
So wie dieses eine...
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es hieß, dieses Rust-Framework,
was wir uns letztens angeguckt haben.
Aber man kann es zumindest halbwegs lesen
Das ist schon mal ganz nice
Also nicht so wie C++
Aber der Hype ist auch ein bisschen weg
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
Vor so 4 Jahren ungefähr
Hat Elixir unseren vollen Hype gehabt
Ich glaube jetzt ist das eher übergegangen
In so normale Usage
machen wir mal eine sache noch diesen monat noch mal kurz rüber scott da irgendwas spannendes
omachi juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt nicht juckt
nicht juckt nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch nicht auch das ist das ding vom vom
theon auch nicht
Ah ja, gut.
Nix Spannendes.
Ah ja, was jetzt voll angesagt ist,
habe ich
im YouTube-Short gesehen.
Wir machen mal kurz LM-Studio.
Starten mal LM-Studio.
Die
Qen
3.8b oder irgendwie
sowas. Wir updaten mal.
Ist angeblich ziemlich gutes lokales model jemand von euch schon mal ausprobiert
Kann man, können wir mal kurz ausprobieren ob das was taugt wir fragen das mal ich weiß was wir fragen wir fragen das mal es soll mir
Eine rust app zum auslesen des endplus heartbeat sensors generieren und n usb verwenden
Gucken wir mal was quen 38 b irgend etwas was das kann
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich richtig benannt habe überhaupt
Mach keine Fehler.
Extra lange nachdenken.
Fehler strictly
nicht allowed.
Okay, wie hat man diesen
Krempe...
Äh...
Update.
Wir updaten einfach alles.
Okay.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
So, hier? Ne.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
wie man das bedient. Hier, so. Load Model.
Ne, das ist das alte.
Hier, NLMs.
Und jetzt?
Wie hat man da jetzt was hin?
Ach, hier, genau. Hier,
QWEN 3870B.
Download.
Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen, bis das runtergeladen ist.
Ich hoffe, der Riemen ruckelt nicht.
Hat man dafür genug Rechenleistung?
Ja.
Passt ja alles in die Grafikkarte.
Das ist ja nur 17,74 Gigabyte.
Und wie viel RAM hat meine Grafikkarte?
24 Gig?
Was hat eine 4090?
24, gell?
Ja, ja, ich glaube schon.
40 90 wie viel ram 24 gig ja hast du mal lm fit das habe ich gilt habe ich noch nicht angeschaut
das habe ich mal gelesen damit kannst du irgendwelche models ja also auch größere
Models auf kleineren Rechnern
irgendwie betreiben.
Das habe ich tatsächlich mal gelesen.
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Topic. Okay.
Zeig mal her.
Da hast du dir
wieder was Schönes rausgesucht.
Mikrocontroller Forum
in Punkt net
at its best
Du bist hier das verabschwürdige
verabscheuungswürdige
Ich sag doch, in dem Forum geht es immer ab, Alter
Was haben sie denn eigentlich
für Probleme?
Um was geht es eigentlich?
Automatisierung Hausgarten
Okay
Das ist halt typisches Mikrocontroller-Formengelaber.
Typical Microcontroller-Forum, ja.
So, also der Download dauert jetzt ein bisschen.
Wir müssen immer den 18-Gig runterladen, ne?
Ich sollte bei der Gelegenheit, während das hier runterlädt,
mal die anderen, die die alten löschen.
Weil die brauchen ja alle unsinnig viel Speicherplatz.
Macht ja keinen Sinn, ne?
Was? Geh weg.
Okay, ist downloadet noch.
Dann lass uns mal gucken, was wir uns auf YouTube anschauen können.
Während der Download läuft.
Was haben wir hier? Lokale KI.
Was ich über lokale KI gelernt habe.
Moment, wir probieren das jetzt das neue Quellenmodel selbst aus.
Der Held auf der Gamescom.
X-Heads Shutdown Nitta.
Ja.
Berlin wird von Hackern erpresst.
Das können wir
zum KekW mal wieder
uns angucken.
Okay, jetzt zeigt mal her.
Haben sie mal wieder...
Sollen sie wieder auf Fax umsteigen, Leute?
Da kann nichts mehr passieren.
Es ist eine Ausnahmesituation.
Wow, mein Browser.
Mein Browser.
Was ist jetzt?
WTF?
Die sieht genauso aus, wie ich mir den IT-Experten vorstelle dort.
Die hat bestimmt richtig krass Ahnung.
Die hat bestimmt auch ganz viele Raspberry Pis und Linux daheim laufen.
Seit gestern.
Der auch, der auch, der bestimmt auch.
Nachmittag, bestimmt richtig krasses Homelab am Start, 17.30 Uhr war es ungefähr, haben wir jetzt eine neue Erkenntnis, denn das Land Berlin wird von den Tätern erpresst.
Wir haben deshalb gestern sehr kurzfristig die Innensenatorin und ich mit den Sicherheitsbehörden des Landes und des Bundes Kontakt aufgenommen.
Wir hatten heute Morgen um 9.30 Uhr eine gemeinsame Sitzung mit den Sicherheitsbehörden.
Ja, mich würde ja mal eher interessieren, wer da wieder in der E-Mail auf irgendeinen Anhang geklickt hat.
Und warum das überhaupt möglich ist, dass es mit so einem Mist immer noch lahmgelegt werden kann.
Mehr Details gibt es offiziell nicht. Aus Teilnehmerkreisen und Krisensitzungen erfährt die ABB, dass es sich um eine Lösegelderpressung handelt, die sehr kurzfristig vom Land Berlin erfüllt werden soll.
Ja gut, die übliche Geschichte, wir haben euer Netzlaufwerk verschlüsselt wahrscheinlich.
Der Spiegel berichtet von 30 Bitcoin oder 2 Millionen Euro.
Bei den Tätern soll es sich um die international agierende Cyber-Kriminalitätsgang WeSeeder handeln,
die in anderen deutschen Städten durch ähnliche Straftaten auffiel.
Gelistet auch auf der Website des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Egal in welcher Höhe und wie die Erpressung stattfindet, wir werden nicht zulassen,
dass diese Erpressung in der Bundeshauptstadt und in Berlin erfolgt.
Im Darknet...
Ja Moment, erfolgt? Erfolgt ist die Erpressung doch schon.
Sie meinen drauf eingehen?
...droht die Gruppe Lautspiegel sensibel...
Erpresst werden sie doch schon!
...darunter Ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren, Informationen...
Nachgestellte Szene, Leute! Die Hackermans sind wieder am Start, ja!
...über Einrichtungen der kritischen Infrastruktur, Notfallpläne und Passwörter.
Die Angaben der Hacker und die Authentizität der gezeigten Dokumente ließen sich nach Spiegelangaben bisher nicht unabhängig verifizieren.
All diese Daten können missbraucht werden.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich genau los?
Können sie genutzt werden, um sich mit Fake-Identitäten an irgendwelchen Diensten anzumelden, um illegale Tätigkeiten auszuführen unter den Namen der anderen Personen.
Oder sie können auch vielleicht für Betrugsfälle direkt benutzt werden.
Siehste, wieder ein weiterer Punkt gegen Massenüberwachung und massenhaft Daten sammeln, weil wir sehen es ja immer wieder, die sind einfach nicht in der Lage, das Zeug sicher zu speichern.
Wenn es zum Beispiel um Zahlungsdaten geht.
Die Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Opposition fordern schnelle Konsequenzen für die Cybersicherheit.
Wir sehen hier nochmal, wie anfällig gerade auch das Berliner Netz ist.
By the way, warum ist das eigentlich immer Berlin? Das stimmt ja nicht, woanders auch.
Das ist ein Berliner Netz aus meiner Sicht heraus, schon bei der Digitalisierung mit einer kleinen Starterei zu tun.
Wie kriegen wir das Netz so geschlossen, dass sowas nicht mehr passiert? Wie kriegen wir Verfahren an?
Vielleicht mal irgendwas machen, was nicht 20 Jahre alt ist, wäre doch schon mal nice.
Besser strukturiert, besser strukturiert.
Der Fehler liege im System.
Jede Verwaltung macht immer noch ihre eigene Administration und deswegen sind solche Hacks
schwerer zu handeln, als wenn man sozusagen ein zentralisiertes Datennetz hätte.
Erst Anfang der Woche konnten die Server der gehackten Senatsverwaltungen wieder ans Netz
genommen werden.
Doch nun ist klar, die Berlinerinnen und Berliner müssen offenbar weiter befürchten, dass
ihre Daten missbraucht werden könnten.
Tja, kacke, ne?
Das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich genau Sache gewesen?
Ja, als Unternehmen musst du bei jedem Furz das direkt melden und alles hin und her.
Aber was da jetzt Sache ist, da wird man wahrscheinlich jetzt gar nichts mehr von hören.
Mit 30 Jahren Leben, be like.
Von Katzen erklärt.
Was ist, ey, was heißt 30?
Ich bin schon, ich bin schon 40.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
In den 30ern sein.
Erklärt von Katzen.
Katze dachte, die 30er würden sich erfolgreich und geordnet anfühlen.
Stattdessen freut Katze sich plötzlich über Heißluftfritteusen und Rückenstützen.
Manche Katzen sind verheiratet, manche geschieden, manche reich.
Manche fangen komplett neu an.
Das ist der seltsame Teil.
Die meisten Erwachsenen finden immer noch unterwegs heraus, wie alles läuft.
Ist die Stimme KI?
Läuft.
In den 30ern hören Katzen meistens auf, alle beeindrucken zu wollen.
Und fangen stattdessen an, ihre Ruhe zu schützen.
Besserer Schlaf.
Ist das so?
Kleinere Freundeskreise, weniger Drama.
Welche Freunde?
Außerdem macht Katzes Körper jetzt zufällige Geräusche beim Aufstehen.
Weise alte Katzen sagen, die 30er sind meistens die Zeit, in der Katzen aufhören so zu tun und anfangen ehrlicher zu werden.
Fühlt sich immer noch wie 21, trotzdem eine gute Katze.
In den 30er sind...
Hä?
Seht euch das Video an.
Wie 1200 Again Hugging Face Hacken.
Ey, das hab ich nicht mitbekommen. Ich hab mitbekommen, dass Hugging Face wurde jetzt verkauft, gell?
An...
Amma? Nee, Nvidia.
Nvidia, genau.
Nvidia.
Wie 1.200 Agenten Huggingface hacken.
Lass mal gucken.
Ich, ich, ich, ich, warte jetzt.
Alter, wie lahm ist denn der Download?
Kann das sein, dass das ganz viele grad runterladen?
13, Leute.
Wir haben ein Problem.
13 Stunden left.
Das ist ein bisschen zu lang.
Ja, aber der Download geht normalerweise schneller.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt geht es schneller.
Nice.
Aber wirklich schnell ist es immer noch nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Downloaden einfach gerade so viele kann das sein.
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal laufen.
Aber es wird immer langsamer.
Kann man über Browser? Ja, theoretisch schon.
Aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es schneller ist, weil letztendlich macht es ja irgendeinen Get-Request.
Also das sollte auch so eine Anwendung halbwegs schnell hinkriegen.
Schauen wir mal, lassen wir mal laden jetzt im Hintergrund.
Was ist das denn?
Dieses unsichtbare Tracking flog zufällig auf.
Stimmt, das habe ich gelesen.
Dass AliExpress auf der Webseite irgendwie Audio aufzeichnet, um die Leute zu tracken.
Das muss ich mir gerade mal angucken, was da jetzt eigentlich genau Sache ist.
Manchmal begegnen uns in der Redaktion Themen, die so wild sind, dass die erste Überprüfung bei der Recherche die ist.
Kann das überhaupt stimmen?
Ja, die China-Chinesen wieder.
Also stellt euch mal vor, ihr öffnet einen Online-Shop und plötzlich funktionieren eure Bluetooth-Kopfhörer nicht mehr richtig.
Genau das ist einem Entwickler passiert, als er AliExpress aufgerufen hat.
Und als er herausfinden wollte, warum seine Kopfhörer plötzlich spinnen, entdeckte er etwas Ungewöhnliches.
AliExpress ließ nämlich im Hintergrund
ein Audiosignal berechnen, das niemand
hören konnte. Und dieses Signal
dient offensichtlich dazu,
den...
Okay, jetzt
verstehe ich das. Die haben nicht
Sound aufgezeichnet von irgendwelchen
Mikros oder so, weil da hat der Browser
ja so ohne weiteres gar keinen
Zugriff drauf. Das machen die
für Fingerprinting.
Also sprich, die lassen
per JavaScript Audio generieren
und die Form dieses
Signals ist wohl relativ unique
pro Gerät. Also
reime ich mir jetzt gerade zusammen.
Browser und das Gerät wieder zu erkennen.
Ja. Das ist nur ein Teil dessen.
Hey, das ist ja eine richtig six-head
Idee von AliExpress. Also nicht, dass ich das gut
finde oder so, aber die Idee ist sehr schlau.
Ja, es gibt ja zig Varianten
zum Tracken
von Browsern und Usern.
Ja, es gab ja auch mal dieses Emoji-Tracking,
Wo man auf ein unsichtbares Canvas Emojis gemalt hat und irgendwie anhand der Draw-Geschwindigkeit und wie die Emojis aussehen erkennen konnten, welche Plattform und welche GPU da drin ist und sowas.
Klingt auch sehr, das ist mit Sicherheit sehr DSGVO-konform, weil die China-Chinesen, die interessieren sich halt einfach nicht für DSGVO.
was die Website über die Besucher erfasst und wie dieses lautlose Tracking funktioniert,
warum ausgerechnet Bluetooth-Kopfhörer es auffliegen ließen und wie ihr euch dagegen schützen könnt.
Ja gut, die Bluetooth-Kopfhörer ließen es auffliegen, weil die Webseite Audio-Kram macht
und deswegen wahrscheinlich die Webseite diese als aktive Audioquelle, die Bluetooth-Kopfhörer gecrapped hat
oder aber die Lautsprecher gecrappt hat und deswegen die Bluetooth-Kopfhörer nicht ging
oder eben die Musik-Player-App nicht funktioniert hat.
Die Geschichte beginnt mit dem Entwickler Matthew Callahan und seinen Multipoint-Bluetooth-Kopfhörern.
Multipoint, das wissen wahrscheinlich die meisten von euch, bedeutet, dass sich die Kopfhörer gleichzeitig
beispielsweise mit Smartphone und Computer verbinden können und oft auch automatisch.
Also ich wusste nicht, dass das Multi-Point heißt, aber das mache ich mit meinen Kopfhörern auch.
Die sind auch an beiden Handys verbunden.
Also wenn ich Musik höre mit dem privaten Handy, kann ich trotzdem Anrufen von der Arbeit bekommen und sowas.
Normalerweise hörte Callaghan Musik vom Smartphone, spielte der PC etwas ab, dann bekam der Computer Vorrang.
Nur plötzlich funktionierte das dann nicht mehr und irgendwann bemerkte Callahan einen erstaunlichen Zusammenhang.
Das Problem trat nämlich auf, wenn AliExpress in seinem Browser geöffnet war.
Obwohl dort weder Musik noch ein Video lief, verhielten sich seine Kopfhörer dann so, als würde der Computer gerade Ton wiedergeben.
Er schloss also testweise den AliExpress-Tab und die Kopfhörer wechselten wieder zum Smartphone.
Er öffnete AliExpress und das Problem kam zurück.
Selbst das Stummschalten des Tabs oder des Browsers half nicht.
Also schaute er genauer hin.
Dabei stieß er auf zwei JavaScript-Dateien. Der Code war sehr kryptisch, aber schnell war ersichtlich, dass beide Skripte eine Funktion nutzen, die praktisch jeder moderne Browser beherrscht. Die Web-Audio-API. Die kann man sich wie ein virtuelles kleines Tonstudio im Browser vorstellen. Eine Webseite kann einen Tongenerator aufstellen, diesen mit einem Analysegerät verbinden, anschließend einen Lautstärkeregler dazwischen schalten und das Ganze schließlich mit der virtuellen Audioausgabe verbinden. All das findet innerhalb dieser API statt.
Normalerweise braucht man das beispielsweise für Spiele, für Videokonferenzen oder Musikanwendungen.
AliExpress baute damit aber eine bemerkenswerte Kette auf. Am Anfang stand ein Tongenerator,
der erzeugte eine sogenannte Sägezahnwelle. Das ist ein Signal mit vielen Obertönen und
eignet sich deshalb gut als Testsignal. Anschließend wurde gemessen, wie der
Browser dieses Signal verarbeitet. Und genau hier wird es interessant,
denn zwei Computer berechnen ein solches Audiosignal nicht unbedingt vollkommen identisch.
Prozessor, Betriebssystem, Browser, Treiber und andere Komponenten können dafür sorgen, dass...
Das ist eine richtig clevere Idee von AliExpress gewesen.
Wie gesagt, nicht, dass ich es gut finde, aber die Idee ist wirklich sehr schlau.
...minimal unterscheiden. Und diese Unterschiede lassen sich messen.
Daraus kann man wiederum ein Merkmal für einen sogenannten Browser Fingerprint erstellen.
Wichtig dabei, AliExpress musste dafür weder auf euer Mikrofon zu greifen,
noch heimlich irgendwelche Geräusche...
Also, sieh mal, die China-Chinesen sind ganz schön feifert.
Im Zimmer aufnehmen. Es geht um Berechnungen innerhalb des Browsers.
Das erzeugte Signal wurde außerdem am Ende auf Lautstärke 0 gesetzt.
Zu hören war deshalb nichts.
Die für den Fingerabdruck interessanten Messwerte waren zu diesem Zeitpunkt ohnehin schon ermittelt.
Und damit wären wir bei dem kleinen Fehler, durch den die Sache überhaupt aufgeflogen ist.
Obwohl die Lautstärke auf 0 stand, wurde das trotzdem mit der Audioausgabe des Computers verbunden.
Für das Betriebssystem sah es dadurch so aus, als würde der Browser Audio verarbeiten.
Und genau deshalb blieben Callahans Kopfhörer am Computer hängen.
Das Spannende daran, für die eigentliche Messung wäre diese Verbindung zur Audioausgabe offenbar gar nicht nötig gewesen.
Ohne dieses virtuelle Kabel hätte Callahan gar keinen Grund gehabt, sich den Code von AliExpress genauer anzusehen.
Ein praktisch lautloses Fingerprinting-Verfahren ist also ausgerechnet an einem Paar Bluetooth-Kopfhörer aufgeflogen.
Und Web Audio ist nur ein Teil der Geschichte.
Die gefundenen Skripte erfassen bzw. prüfen noch zahlreiche weitere Eigenschaften.
Darunter Informationen über den Bildschirm und Browser, Arbeitsspeicher und CPU-Kerne, WebGL und Canvas, unterstützte Medienformate, WebRTC sowie Maus.
Ja, da kannst du einen ziemlich guten Fingerprint erstellen.
Früher, was sehr beliebt war für Fingerprinting, waren Schriftarten und Font-Rendering.
Aber da hat man, also User-Agent kannst du eh vergessen, da hat man ja mittlerweile einen Riegel vorgeschoben.
Tja, aber das alles in Kombination gibt wahrscheinlich einen ziemlich eindeutigen Hinweis, welches Gerät das ist.
Touch, Scroll und andere Nutzerinteraktionen. Das Prinzip dahinter nennt sich Browser Fingerprinting. Stellt euch jeden einzelnen Messwert wie ein Puzzleteil vor. Eine Bildschirmauflösung von 2,5...
Also ich meine, das Ziel ist klar. Die wollen Geräte und damit höchstwahrscheinlich auch User über Cookie-Grenzen und sowas hinweg tracken können.
Also auch wenn du im anonymen Surf-Modus bist oder wenn du dein Cache leerst oder was auch immer, deine IP wechselst, wollen die trotzdem weiterhin wissen, dass du das bist und dass das Gerät das ist.
560x1440 Pixel ist natürlich nicht einzigartig. Chrome in einer bestimmten Version auch nicht,
eine bestimmte Grafikkarte ebenfalls nicht. Kombiniert man aber sehr viele solcher
Merkmale miteinander, wird die Kombination zunehmend charakteristisch. So kann ein
Browser mit relativ hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit wiedererkannt werden. Und dafür braucht es
keinen klassischen Tracking-Cookie. Allerdings ist an dieser Stelle eine Einschränkung wichtig.
Wir wissen nicht, ob AliExpress diesen Fingerabdruck tatsächlich benutzt, um euch über verschiedene Webseiten hinweg für Werbung zu verfolgen.
Wir wissen das nicht, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn sie den Fingerabdruck da errechnen.
Ja.
Die beiden Skripte, die scheinen zu Alibabas System für Sicherheit und Missbrauch.
Also die Chancen sind doch schon mal da.
Dafür wird Browser Fingerprinting eingesetzt.
Ein Online-Shop kann damit beispielsweise versuchen zu erkennen, ob hinter mehreren vermeintlich unterschiedlichen Nutzern immer dasselbe Gerät steckt oder ob automatisierte Bots auf die Seite zugreifen.
Der Entwickler, der die Skripte entdeckt hat, sagt selbst, dass er nicht sehen kann, was AliExpress anschließend auf seinen Servern mit den gesammelten Daten macht.
Das Datenschutzproblem bleibt trotzdem.
Solche Fingerprints entstehen weitgehend unsichtbar und sind für den Nutzer wesentlich schwerer zu kontrollieren als Cookies.
Denn Cookies könnt ihr löschen und ihr könnt sie unterbinden.
Eure Kombination aus Browser, Hardware und Systemeigenschaften lässt sich dagegen nicht mal eben so löschen.
Bevor wir dazu kommen, wie ihr euch dagegen schützen könnt, noch ein kurzer Hinweis in eigener Sache.
Wenn euch solche Geschichten interessieren und ihr bei IT- und Technikthemen gerne noch etwas tiefer einsteigt, schaut euch...
Warum lässt man eigentlich zu, dass der Browser... Naja, weil das ganz normale Standard-APIs vom Browser sind.
Was willst du dagegen machen?
Was du machen könntest ist,
was du machen könntest ist,
du könntest ein Custom Browser-Bild
verwenden oder deine Settings
vom Browser
anpassen,
um diese APIs zu deaktivieren,
aber dann hast du das Problem, dass vielleicht manche Webseiten nicht funktionieren.
Was ist eine unnötige Aussage?
Ich habe gerade nicht zugehört. Ich habe gerade dem Max im Discord
geantwortet.
Schaut euch doch mal Heise Plus an.
Dort findet ihr ausführliche Hintergrundberichte, Tests, Ratgeber und Analysen und außerdem digitalen Zugriff auf die Magazine aus dem Heise-Kosmos.
Aktuell bekommt ihr Heise Plus für 12 Wochen mit 50% Rabatt.
Alle Infos findet ihr unter heiseplus.de.
Bleibt also die Frage, kann man sich gegen Fingerprinting schützen?
Komplett verhindern lässt es sich nur schwer.
Aber bei den beiden konkret gefundenen AliExpress-Skripten kann man beispielsweise uBlock Origin dann einsetzen.
Callaghan hat Filterregeln veröffentlicht, mit denen sich die beiden JavaScript-Dateien gezielt blockieren lassen.
Das hat allerdings zwei Nachteile.
Erstens können sich die Adressen der Skripte ändern.
Und zweitens scheinen sie zur Sicherheits- und Antimissbrauchs-Infrastruktur von Alibaba zu gehören.
Wer sie also blockiert, der könnte deshalb beispielsweise häufiger Captcha-Abfragen sehen oder Probleme beim Login oder Checkout bekommen.
Wenn du als einziger auf der Welt die API blockiert hast, ist es auch eindeutig.
Eine grundsätzlichere Schutzmaßnahme bieten Browser, die Fingerprinting erschweren.
Brave verändert beispielsweise bestimmte zurückgelieferte Werte, damit Webseiten keinen stabilen Fingerabdruck daraus erzeugen können.
Auch Safari verfügt über Schutzmechanismen gegen Fingerprinting und Firefox versucht ebenfalls, die für Webseiten unsichtbaren Unterschiede zwischen Nutzern zu reduzieren.
Interessanterweise hat Mozilla Security Engineer Tom Ritter das konkrete AliExpress-Verfahren
untersucht.
Sein Ergebnis zeigt auch, warum man bei solchen Geschichten mit Begriffen wie eindeutiger
Fingerabdruck vorsichtig sein sollte.
Zumindest unter Firefox liefert diese konkrete Audio-Methode bei sehr vielen Nutzern dieselben
wenigen Werte.
Das Audio-Verfahren allein reicht also keineswegs zwangsläufig aus, um euch eindeutig zu identifizieren.
Interessant wird es durch die Kombination mit vielen anderen Merkmalen.
Genau das macht den Fall AliExpress so bemerkenswert.
Nicht, weil plötzlich irgendein Online-Shop heimlich über eure Lautsprecher Ultraschall aussendet.
Das passiert hier nicht.
Sondern weil eine ganz normale Browserschnittstelle, die eigentlich für Spiele, Musik und Web-Anwendungen gedacht ist,
gleichzeitig Informationen liefern kann, die für Fingerprinting interessant sind.
Normalerweise bekommt ihr davon überhaupt nichts mit.
Diesmal gab es aber einen winzigen Nebeneffekt.
Ausgerechnet ein Bluetooth-Problem hat damit sichtbar gemacht, was im Browser eigentlich nicht funktioniert.
Die werden halt immer erfinderischer.
Aber das ist, also ich muss sagen
Hut ab da
Vor AliExpress, die Idee finde ich sehr schlau
Guck mal, wir haben ein neues
FireShip Video
Komm, wir gucken mal
Komm, wir gucken mal FireShip
Wir haben schon eine ganze Weile kein Fire Ship mehr geguckt.
Was macht eigentlich mein Download?
17 Stunden.
Fuck, Alter.
Ich glaube, die throtteln hier.
Das stimmt, aber es gibt mittlerweile so viele Security-Inzidenz und Datenleaks, dass es schon mittlerweile keinen mehr juckt.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
Die Software hat immer mit Ducktape zusammengehalten und der Poverty von Open Source Maintainers.
Und es gibt kein besseres Beispiel dafür, als das, was eine Firma 14 Jahre ago mit organischer menschlicher Verrücktheit gemacht hat.
In etwa 45 Minuten an einem randomen Dienstag,
war Knight Capital, der zu einem Zeitpunkt 10% der ganzen Stockhandels in den USA verantwortlich war,
ein Verlust von 440 Millionen Dollar und vier Monate später wurde für Teile gesolden.
In diesem Video schauen wir uns an, was die teuerste Software-Bug in der Geschichte verursacht hat
und lernen, wie man in einer Minute 10 Millionen Dollar verliert, mit diesem einen seltsamen Trick.
Es ist August 27, 2026 und ihr schaut den Code-Report.
Im Jahr 2012, während die anderen von uns auf Gasstationen und der Mayan-Apokalypse warten,
war Night Capital ständig als der größte Marktmacher auf Wall Street,
als es 20 Millionen Dollar in Trades jeden Tag verarbeitet hat.
Wenn ihr euch zurück erinnert, wie die GameStop-Robinhood-Saga von ein paar Jahren her war,
war Night Capital im Grunde die Zitadelle ihrer Zeit.
Wann auch immer ein Ape wie du oder ich ein Stock von einem Verkaufsverkauf wie E-Trade kaufen würde,
The brokerage didn't actually execute the trade themselves.
Instead, they'd often pass it off to Knight, who would fill the order and pocket the spread.
At its core was a system called SMARS,
which was an order router that took large orders and chopped them up into smaller orders
to fill them across the market at the best prices.
It was fast, reliable, and more importantly, it printed money for over a decade.
Then, in the summer of 2012, the New York Stock Exchange decided it was sick of watching firms like Knight
skimmen alle Retail-Order aus, bevor sie den echten Exchange erreichen.
Es hat also ein Retail-Liquiditätsprogramm geschaffen,
das sich im Grunde genommen auf seine eigene Version des Business-Modells von Knight verwendet,
um Order zurückzubekommen, mit etwas besseren Preisen.
Die SEC hat es im Juni mit einem Go-Live-Date von August 1st verabschiedet.
Und weil Knight auch einer der größten Kunden des Exchange war,
wurden sie gezwungen, es zu implementieren.
Und so haben sie es begonnen.
Und wie jede große finanzielle Institution,
die für die Leidenschaft von hart arbeitenden, blauen Amerikanern verantwortlich ist,
Sie haben es mit Gnade und Gnade gemacht.
Nur eine Verabschiedung, sie haben es in der lauschesten Weise möglich gemacht.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war die alte Feature Flagge, die seit 2003 nicht benutzt wurde, aber nie verlagert wurde.
Fliegen der Flagge würde eine Testfunktion genannt, die Power Peg, die ein paar Bauen-Order ausüben würde,
damit Knight die Frage, wie der Preis der Stock reagiert, beantworten könnte.
Und da der ganze Punkt war, die Preise umzuschalten, war es designt,
aggressiv zu kaufen, bei der aktuellen Marktpreise, mit null Wunsch, einen guten Deal zu bekommen.
Ah.
Ey, es war 2012.
Ja.
Erstmal Stecker ziehen.
So schnell kann's gehen.
Ah ja?
so schnell kann es gehen, wenn man nicht aufpasst.
Oh, jetzt downloadet er schneller.
Deswegen fragen
Leute, ihr fragt euch teilweise
sicherlich, ich frag mich das ja auch,
warum haben
Banken und so, warum haben die noch
alte Kobol-Sachen laufen?
Eines der Hauptgründe ist,
weil es funktioniert.
Und es traut sich keiner mehr anzufassen,
weil sowas kann passieren.
und das kann die bescheuertsten Gründe haben.
Ja, und selbst wenn ihr sagt, okay,
wir lassen den alten Kobold-Code konvertieren nach Java,
irgendein Default-Verhalten ändert sich und es passiert sowas.
Ist halt kacke.
Deswegen lässt man lieber 30, 40 Jahre alten Kobold-Code weiterlaufen,
von dem man weiß, er funktioniert.
Am besten fasst ihn auch niemals jemand wieder an.
Gucken wir jetzt das noch.
1002 Agents Hugging Face Hack Walls.
Vielleicht haben wir ja noch Glück und es wird irgendwann mal fertig.
Also der könnte hiermit deutlich mehr runterladen, ne?
Als mit 1,72.
Der könnte hiermit 40, 50 MB runterladen.
Aber will er nicht.
Ich lasse den jetzt einfach mal laufen.
So, dann gucken wir uns das nächste Stream an.
Wahrscheinlich habt ihr schon gehört, dass OpenAI-SKI-Modelle Hugging Face gehackt haben.
Moment.
Ja, das habe ich gehört.
Ist das nicht das?
Ist das dieser Hack? Ist das nicht der, der aus Versehen passiert ist?
Wo irgendein Model irgendwo ausgebrochen ist?
War das nicht die Geschichte?
Unsloth Desktop wechseln.
Was ist denn das? Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ist das quasi Versus LM Studio?
Okay.
Aber ich war ausgerechnet.
Ich lasse das jetzt erstmal laufen.
Ich meine, ich könnte theoretisch das runterladen und in Ulama starten.
Ich habe selbst sogar schon einen Short darüber gemacht.
Und seitdem wurde die Geschichte einmal quer durchs Internet gedreht.
Und eigentlich war für jede Meinung irgendwas dabei.
Für die einen war das der große Ausbruch einer Hacker-KI.
für die anderen einfach eine sehr aufwendige Marketingkampagne von OpenAI.
Nur, was genau diese Agenten technisch gemacht haben und sich dabei gegenseitig...
Was macht eigentlich...
Kurz, kurz ein Haken, falls das jemand von euch verfolgt.
Was macht eigentlich der Rust-Rewrite von BUN?
Die haben doch jetzt die erste Version released, die in Rust-Rewrite ist.
Gibt's da Probleme?
Oder ist das alles...
easy gewesen?
Weiß das jemand?
Ist da jemand so am Puls der Zeit, was BAN angeht?
Wir können doch gerade mal kurz gucken.
Das interessiert mich.
GitHub BAN.
Issues.
Okay, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt an Rust liegt oder nicht.
Wir gucken uns das mal irgendeinen random Bug an.
Das da, genau.
Vielleicht liegt das an Rust, man weiß es nicht.
Blazingly Fast, natürlich ist Blazingly Fast.
Alles in Rust war Blazingly Fast.
... auch geschrieben haben, konnten wir bisher kaum beurteilen.
Wir hatten Schlagzeilen und natürlich sehr viel Interpretation.
Aber das hat sich jetzt geändert.
OpenAI hat einen 38 Seiten langen Technical Report veröffentlicht.
Meter, ein unabhängiges Forschungsinstitut, hat unabhängig davon die Agententranskripte
und das gesamte Messageboard, das die Agenten benutzt haben, untersucht.
Und in diesen beiden Berichten stecken endlich die Details, die an der ganzen Story wirklich
interessieren.
Code of...
Oh ne, das...
So gerne ich Morpheus Videos gucke, aber ein Video über einen 38 Seiten Report, das halte
ich jetzt geistig gerade nicht aus.
Oh.
Das mir zu, das mir zu anstrengend.
Der Report ist KI generiert.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass er Teile KI generiert, oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung.
Da blickst du ja mittlerweile nicht mehr durch.
Wie groß ist denn der Performance-Unterschied von lokalen Agents wie Cloud Code oder Codex?
haben wir zumindest nicht mehr so oft vergessen,
bei irgendwelchen Permissionsachen zu drücken.
Du meinst du mit Performance
Unterschied das Können der Models?
Also,
ich habe lange, schätze ich,
das Lokal nicht mehr ausprobiert.
Meine letzten Versuche waren
mit QuenCoder 3.
Die waren,
das war not even close.
Ja, das konntest du nicht wirklich verwenden, obwohl das damals mit das Beste für lokale KI war.
Für Agents war QuenCoder 3 gar nichts, weil Tool Usage dann richtig funktioniert hat.
Also sowas wie Bash-Befehle ausführen, gucken in Dateien, das hat nicht richtig funktioniert, das konntest du komplett knicken.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt besser mit dem neuen Model.
Aber selbst dann lehne ich mich jetzt mal aus dem Fenster, ohne dass ich es bis jetzt ausprobiert habe.
glaube ich, dass das Können von gerade Opus 5 und den Anthropix Sachen
oder vielleicht auch den neuen GPT-5-6-Dingern,
wobei ich die noch nicht großartig ausprobiert habe,
wahrscheinlich immer noch eine ganze Ecke besser ist als die lokalen Models.
Aber vielleicht reichen die lokalen Models aus.
Kann man denn, du machst das, kann man, wenn Coder 3.8, kann man das online benutzen?
Kann man da das Model auswählen?
Okay.
Guck mal, was er sagt.
ja und das ist
das ist 38
die webseite geht nicht geil
ok wir machen mal wir machen mal hier dark reader aus und wir machen hier mal
kurz U-Block
Origin aus. Keine Quelle.
Okay, das funzt.
Oder Lunwe.
Oh.
Das ist wohl...
Oh, das ist eine komplizierte Antwort.
Oh.
Okay.
Dann fragen wir das doch mal. Neuer Chat.
Neuer Chat. AI.
Ich brauche ein
Rust-Programm, das
per
N plus Stick
einen Heartbeat-Sensor
ausliest. Benutze
Rust und NUSP.
Bam.
Mal gucken, was da jetzt rauskommt.
Mal gucken, ob da was Sinnvolles rauskommt bei.
Also das ist die bessere Variante von dem,
was man auch lokal laufen lassen kann.
Stelle auf Thinking?
Oh ja.
Du hast recht, das muss man doch umstellen.
Aber ich glaube, es denkt schon.
Es denkt, Leute.
Es ist im High IQ Mode.
Denkt es immer noch?
Oh ja, es denkt noch.
Es ist richtig hart am Denken.
Five-Hat-Time.
Mal gucken, wie lang es denkt.
Ich meine, es denkt mit Sicherheit nicht so schnell, wie wenn du ein Abo hast.
Aber mal gucken, wie lang es braucht.
Es denkt aber ganz schön lang.
Bald Timeout ist bestimmt.
Ne, ne, es denkt immer noch.
Oder hat es...
Ist es abgekackt beim Denken, Leute?
Was auch von Alibaba ist,
weiß ich nicht.
Welch du Deck.
Also es denkt, es denkt noch.
Also schnell, schnell denken tut es nicht.
Aber gucken, vielleicht ist ja das Ergebnis gut, was es denkt.
Wenn du viel Zeit in Linux verwendest...
Ich prädikte jetzt mal.
Ich prädikte jetzt mal, was da drinnen vorkommt.
Da drinnen kommt vor...
FZF.
BAT.
NeoWim.
EXA anstatt LS.
Üblichen Verdächtigen.
Ja, B-Top.
Written in Rust. Wir können uns
das theoretisch sparen.
Aha! Bam!
Ups, jetzt habe ich mein Mikrofon
irgendwie gerade geprickt.
Jetzt, okay.
Wir können uns das Video einfach sparen.
Wir gucken einfach hier unten, ob da irgendwas Spannendes drin ist.
Bad. Das dachte ich mir.
Wobei man sagen muss,
Bad an sich ist wirklich cool.
Ich benutze es halt nicht.
Wegen den
Sachen, die ich
sonst auch immer anspreche. Und zwar, also ich kann es, ich kann es
ja mal zeigen, ja. Gehen wir jetzt einfach mal
hier rein. So, gucken wir uns jetzt
irgendwie das da an.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Easy, easy, easy. Klingt
aber gut. Easy, so. Cat,
Notepie. So, zack. So.
Das ist halt nicht Gesündtagshighlight.
Und wenn ich das mit Bad mache,
kriegt man das halt gepaged und
Gesündtagshighlight zurück. Ja.
Das ist schon ganz cool.
Wobei ich halt ehrlich sagen muss, wenn ich
das brauche, dann mache ich
es einfach in einem Editor auf. Und das habe ich
auch. Ja, also, deswegen diese
Sachen. Ja, BAT ist
ganz cool,
aber ich verwende es nicht,
aus dem gleichen Grund, wie ich viele andere
Rust-Rewritten-Tools nicht verwende.
Ich bin so oft per SSH
auf dem Server drauf,
dass ich dann verlerne, wie die
Standard-Tools funktionieren. Und diese ganzen Extra-Dinger
sind ja nicht auf Servern drauf.
Es ist halt nicht
auf Server-Default drauf. Genau.
ja bett page und syntax highlight und alles also quasi ein bisschen bisschen
cat lässt mit syntax highlighting zusammen also ob man das jetzt braucht ich habe da
meine zweifel ja ich kann es einfach so und wenn ich wenn ich scrollen will und
syntax highlighting brauchen dann brauchst du also ich habe dann für mich jetzt nicht so
den den kassen anwendungs weil ich sage das brauche ich unbedingt aber schau mal wie gesagt
alles was auf server nicht default ist benutze ich ungerne regelmäßig als ersatz für tools die
auch im server stand hat mäßig drauf sind weil dann verlernen ich wie man es benutzt ja deswegen
ist meine lokale wimcon fake halt auch sehr übersichtlich ja ich habe kein wirken ich habe
kein neo werden und ich habe nichts großartiges gesetzt kommen wir gucken uns das machen guck mal
mal was er sagt.
Enterprise.
Wir können mal.
Er ist so langsam.
1,5 ist optimal, oder?
Etsy. Ich sage immer ETC.
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Etsy?
etc. etc.
Ich sag etc.
Slash etc.
Ich sag auch slash user,
nicht slash user.
Aber Leertaste
oder geklickt halten
macht zweifach. Ich will 1,5-fach.
Naja, also
der Output von cat ist doch nicht
super difficult to read. Der Output
von Cat ist genauso difficult to read
wie halt die Datei
ist. Und wenn ich Syntax-Highlighting und
Scrolling brauche, mache ich es eben im Editor auf.
Ich kann Bad Cat, Docker Compose, YAML.
Wenn ich ein Compose-File oder ein Konfig-File lese,
ist das eine dieser kleinen Änderungen, die den Terminal absolut viel besser fühlen.
Das nächste Tool ist der FD-Kommand, welches eine viel freundlichere Alternative ist.
Find ist extrem stark und ich denke immer noch, dass es
Wie wichtig ist, das ist eine interessante Frage,
wie wichtig ist es überhaupt, gut mit WIM zu können?
Altere Kollegen schwören drauf, junge Kollegen nutzen auf Nano.
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also was dein Job ist.
Wenn du Entwickler bist und nur unregelmäßig mal auf Linux-Kisten unterwegs bist,
kannst du auch Nano verwenden.
Wenn du hauptberuflicher Linux-Admin bist, finde ich, hat es schon einen gewissen Vorteil,
weil Vim ist halt überall drauf.
Ja, sogar auf irgendwelchem Netzwerkequipment.
Vim hast du alles, was Linux-Based ist, hat irgendwie ein UI.
Ja, ist irgendwie drauf.
Also die Basic-Bedienung, und sei es nur, dass du weißt, wie du rauskommst,
ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Ich persönlich mag Vim deutlich lieber als Nano,
weil es sich gut per SSH über SSH bedienen lässt.
Nano auch.
Bei Nano musst du dir aber halt irgendwelche Shortcuts merken,
so Ctrl-X und sowas.
Ich mag das bei Vim mehr.
Ja, aber es ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache.
Du kommst auch mit Nano aus.
Du kannst auch IMAX verwenden.
Der Vorteil von Vim ist, dass es überall drauf ist.
Bei Debian ist Nano aber auch standardmäßig drauf.
Und wahrscheinlich mittlerweile sogar bei recht vielen Distributionen.
Also, du kommst mit Nano aus.
Effektiver, schneller und angenehmer Textfiles über SSH editieren
kann man aber trotzdem...
mit Vim machen, finde ich.
Was soll Ctrl-X machen?
Äh, Ctrl-X
ist bei Nano-Datei
speichern.
Bei Vim ist Ctrl-X
eine Zahl
1 runterrechnen.
Kann ich euch übrigens mal zeigen. By the way,
kennt ihr das?
Ihr habt hier, keine Ahnung,
ihr habt hier
599 stehen,
okay? Wenn ihr jetzt
Ctrl-A drückt, kann Wim das
hochrechnen. Und wenn er jetzt
Ctrl-X drückt, oh fuck.
Äh, Ctrl-X ist eigentlich Minus.
Ctrl-X benutze ich aber so gut wie nie.
Ctrl-X habe ich auf Terminal-Killen gemappt
bei mir. Das funktioniert nicht. Aber
Ctrl-X, also wir können
das mal, okay, wir machen das anders. X-Term, okay?
X-Term. Oldschool as fuck.
Also hier, blubb jetzt hier.
599.
Ups.
599. Ihr drückt jetzt
Ctrl-A. Wim zählt das hoch.
Ihr drückt Ctrl-X. Wim zählt
das runter. Und wisst ihr, was auch
nice ist, was Wim auch kann?
0x
FF. Passt mal auf.
Seht ihr das?
Wim kann sogar Hex
zählen.
Ist das nicht nice?
So, aber genug Flashbang.
Ja, guck hier, ich kann es sagen.
Ich glaube, Wim kann sogar 0, B, 1, 1.
Ich glaube, das kann sogar Binary.
Guck mal, das kann sogar Binary zählen.
Seht ihr das?
Wim kann Binary zählen.
Ist es nicht?
Excellent.
Guck hier.
Immer plus 1.
Ja. Und bei Nano
bei Nano
ist Ctrl-X safe.
Aber das, seht ihr mal.
Fuck Leute, ich hab ein Problem. Ich komme jetzt aus Nano nicht raus,
weil ich Ctrl-X nicht gemappt habe.
Da sieht man mal, wie oft ich Nano verwende.
Okay. Kill all Nano.
Bam.
Genau.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal weiter. Was macht eigentlich mein Download?
Drei Stunden.
Wo sind wir hier stehen geblieben?
FD.
Feind.
Das stimmt.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, das verwende ich tatsächlich auch manchmal.
Das benutze ich tatsächlich auch manchmal.
Einfach weil es sich viel einfacher tippen lässt.
Einfach viel einfacher tippen lässt als Feind.
Aber ich kann Feind immer noch benutzen.
Weil Feind müsstest du zum Beispiel so machen.
Feind.
Punkt.
minus name filter das ist halt eklig das ist das ist das halt deutlich angenehmer
das stimmt da hast du recht da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht hast du vollkommen recht
wenn du hier jetzt kopiert kopiert die zeilen nummern auch mit ja und das ding ist hier kommt
mal dass das sieht man schon daran dass das wieder nicht so geil ist wenn du hier scrolling an hast
kannst du halt nicht markieren und scrollen richtig.
Funktioniert halt nicht.
Und bei Cat absolut kein Problem.
Hier scrollen, markieren, überhaupt kein Ding.
Wahrscheinlich kann man
Bad-N oder so machen, dass es
das ausschaltet.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich
sowas mit Cat mache, dann ist es genau unter anderem
um so Dinger hier zu kopieren.
Also Bad ist...
Ehrlich gesagt
sehe ich den Anwendungszweck von Bad nicht.
Aber FD benutze ich tatsächlich
auch ab und zu mal.
Auf Servern aber immer find, weil find halt standardmäßig auch überall drauf ist.
Und ich denke immer noch, dass es ein Befehl ist, den jeder Linux-Administrator verstehen sollte.
Eine basische Suche wie find etsy-name-star.conf ist nicht zu schlecht.
Aber das Problem ist, dass wenn man anfängt, File-Typen, Pads, Exklusionen, Expressionen und andere Bedingungen zu kombinieren,
dann wird das find-Syntax-Gang ziemlich schrecklich, ziemlich schnell.
FD simplifiziert das viel.
Gerade wenn man FIND noch mit einem EXEC hintendran macht und sowas, dann ist ja eine Frage, es verhält sich ja unterschiedlich, ob du, also wenn ihr sagt jetzt hier FIND, so, und dann sagt ihr EXEC, oder wie ist das, EXEC, so, und dann ist es ein Unterschied, ob ihr blub blub blub so macht oder das weglasst, dann passiert unterschiedliches Zeug.
Ganz wirres Ding, ja.
find dash y. Just like that,
Debian gives this one a slightly different command name,
so you normally run fd find.
If you want the command to simply just be
fd, you can always create an alias and add that
to your dash rc file. Once it is
installed though, something like fd find... Aber da gebe ich ihm recht,
fd ist wirklich nice.
Das benutze ich sogar auch
manchmal, um Sachen zu suchen,
obwohl ich ja Fan von den Default Tools bin.
find dash t f dash e comp
searches for files with a comp extension
and if you're also wanting hidden files,
you can add the dash capital h
option fd also tendenz er hat ja die wim bedienung ist nicht wirklich auf auf
deutsches layout ausgelegt das merkst du halt
bei doppelpunkt und ecken klammern und sowas aber nichtsdestotrotz kommt man
trotzdem mit dem bett mit dem deutschen tastatur layout besser klar weil man
eben an das gewöhnt ist ja also ich kann mittlerweile immer ohne probleme im
deutschen tastatur layout bedienen aber es ist schon wenn man eigentlich das
tastatur layout gewöhnt ist ist schon etwas angenehmer
Aber das ist auch mit deutschen Tastaturlayout kein Problem.
Das wusste ich, dass das drankommt.
Das ist auch was, was es bei mir nicht gibt.
Ich glaube sogar,
CacheOS hat das standardmäßig drauf.
Aber ich verwende das nie.
Ich greppe.
Und ich muss ja sagen, ich bin ja auch noch hier ein richtiger Oldschool-Boomer, was das angeht.
Ich verwende manchmal sogar noch e-KREP, weil ich zu faul bin, KREP-E zu tippen.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich benutze auch weiterhin KREP, weil KREP eben auch auf jedem Serversystem drauf ist.
Und er geht nicht.
I could run grep-R 10.10.10.50.
And grep would search through everything underneath that directory.
Now, RIP-Grep gives you a similar workflow, but it's extremely fast and it has some really nice defaults.
You can install it also with the apt-install RIP-Grep-Y command,
but the actual command that you use is simply RG.
So that same search becomes RG 10.10.10.50.
Aber so eine krasse Ersparnis ist das jetzt auch nicht.
Hier sagst du explizit, was du machen musst.
Und nachdem ich es gewöhnt bin, grepp-Befehle zu tippen und grepp auf dem Server drauf ist, brauche ich kein RG.
Habe ich nicht angesehen, ne.
kode repositories you are not necessarily search einfach mal wieder
krasse sackemann hintergrund video bei den leuten müssen es bis hin zu machen
wenn euch das stream gefällt könnte man der stelle jetzt ja ein follow da lassen
freut mich immer sehr wenn ich sehe dass die pfeile grün nach oben zeigen aus dem
motivierte das mehr zu streamen
und ihr seid den nächsten stream direkt wieder mit am start
Bam!
Direkt einer unfollowed.
Direkt instant unfollowed einer.
Wenn ich versuchen möchte, wo das Spiel geht,
dann könnte ich etwas wie du-sh-star
machen. Das gibt dir eine kurze
Summe.
Next, dankeschön.
Ähm, wie gesagt,
Subscriptions immer super,
top, freue ich mich sehr drüber.
Aber ich freue mich auch über Follows.
Muss kein Subscription sein.
Grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen
und zu sehen, dass die Leute
den Stream gerne gucken und so, ist auch sehr
motivated.
Motivatenend.
Okay, Moment, jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst.
Was benutzt er?
NC-DU instead of D.
Das benutze ich auch.
Ja, das benutze ich auch.
NC-DU ist wirklich nice
Ja, also den Krempel kennt ihr ja
Ups, Moment, bin im falschen Fenster
Den Krempel kennt ihr ja hier, ne
Also quasi gucken, wie groß bestimmte Unterverzeichnisse sind und sowas
By the way, wusstet ihr, wenn ihr das hier weglasst, ne
Wenn ihr das hier weglasst und ihr pipet das nach Sort-S
Sort-N, glaube ich
Irgendwie so
Dann könnt ihr das auch aufsteigend sortieren
Das funzt auch
aber du ist wirklich nur für quick and dirty im verzeichnis kurz gucken ansonsten ist nc du viel
warum habe ich das hier gar nicht sehen wie nice habe ich auf allen meinen servern installiert
es gibt 25 prozent rabatt auf satz aktuell weiß wusste ich gar nicht ja dann besos braucht
unbedingt mehr Geld. Ja, guck hier
NC-DU zum Beispiel.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier mache, so in meinem Heimatverzeichnis,
ne, das ist halt
nicht so doll übersichtlich, was
hier abgeht. Oder gehen wir mal nach Repos rein,
ja. Das ist halt nicht so wirklich übersichtlich,
was hier abgeht mit NC-DU. Wenn ich jetzt NC-DU
mache, zack, dann kriegst du hier so eine
Übersicht, in welchem Ordner
wie viel drin ist
und kannst dann sogar hier rein
navigieren und gucken, was ist hier drin, was ist hier drin,
was ist hier drin, wo ist hier das...
Du kannst sogar darüber löschen, theoretisch.
Also das ist mega nice.
NC-DU ist auch in allen Standard-Repos von allen Distributionen, die ich kenne, dabei.
Und die habe ich auf allen Servern von mir installiert.
NC-DU ist mega praktisch.
Interaktiv.
Sie können sich die Direktoren auswählen und herausfinden, was genau das
Disk-Base verbraucht.
Und die NCDU-Kommande ist exzellent dafür.
Sie können sie mit apt install ncdu-y installieren, in die Direktoren
gehen, die Sie analysieren wollen und einfach die NCDU-Kommande runtern.
Und es wird das Filesystem scanen und Ihnen eine Terminalbasierte Interface geben,
wo Sie mit den Arro-Keys nach oben und nach unten gehen können.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt NC-DU gibt es auch mit mit.
Mit Colors.
Ja, aber wie?
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Geht das wirklich?
Ne, mein NC-DUO hat nie Colors.
Ups.
Das muss ich jetzt gleich mal angucken.
Color?
On? Oder was?
Always?
Äh.
Macht man das?
Okay, Color.
Dark.
Ach, guck mal da.
Das gibt es mit Color.
Okay, sieht zwar ein bisschen hässlich aus, aber das ist in der Tat gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Was gibt es da sonst noch für Alternativen hier zu Color?
Dark gab es.
Dark BG.
Ich sehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt keinen Unterschied.
Ob man das natürlich braucht, sei mal dahingestellt, weil es sieht schon ein bisschen hässlich
aus.
Aber doch, das haben wir wieder was gelernt.
Wusste ich nicht, dass es NC-DU in Color gibt.
Das dachte ich mir schon fast, dass das kommt.
Btop mag ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe es sogar installiert.
Ähm.
Okay, B-Top.
Das ist mir zu viel.
Das ist mir zu viel und unübersichtlich.
Und außerdem hat es das Problem,
dass bei kleineren Fenstern nicht angezeigt werden kann.
Ja, ich mache jetzt mal hier ein bisschen CPU-Last.
Also ich finde B-Top viel zu unübersichtlich
und ich blicke da nicht durch.
Für mich am besten der Goat, was das angeht,
unter dem es nach wie vor H-Top ist.
HATOP auch auf allen Kisten von mir installiert, immer.
StandardTOP ist mir doch auch ein bisschen zu minimalistisch, ja.
Aber HATOP ist für mich das Beste, was es gibt.
Zumal es seit zwei Jahren oder so jetzt auch dieses IOTAP hat
und du gucken kannst, welche Prozesse wie viel Disk-IO machen.
Das Feature, was ich mir noch wünschen würde für HATOP,
wäre tatsächlich
noch ein dritten Tab,
der das hier hatte.
Netzwerk-Traffic.
Aber am liebsten Netzwerk-Traffic
pro Prozess, falls das möglich ist.
Das wäre noch mega.
Netzwerk-Traffic pro Prozess.
Das wäre exzellent.
Das hätte ich gerne.
Das fände ich mega nice.
Meine KI war fertig.
Ach, die China-KI ist fertig.
Okay, also.
Ja, ja.
source ms message version okay ganz viel geduld hier end message parser
sync byte wenn keins vorhanden ist ist der ist der baffermüll ich finde gut
dass es klartext spricht dieses model
zum beizuchen wenn keins vorhanden ist ist der baffermüll sehr gut
Alles vor dem Sync-Byte verwerfen.
Ja, auch sinnvoll.
Mindestens Sync plus Slangs plus Message-ID plus Checksum.
Ja.
War das Sync-Byte fair?
Ja, was?
Okay, wenn ich das Copy-Paste,
kann ich es dann lesen?
Okay.
Wenn hier ein unrealistischer Wert steht,
war der Sync, war der
Sync Byte vermutlich falsch.
Naja, aber das sieht doch schon mal ganz sinnvoll aus,
was das hier, was das hier zusammenwurschtelt.
Also das scheint, das kann man echt gebrauchen hier, das China-Chinesen-Model.
Und wo wir jetzt das Highlight nehmen, ja Rust, der checkt es nicht, wenn es einfach so öffnet.
Du kannst, ähm, warte mal, Syntax on Vim.
What the fuck, was jetzt?
Äh, set Syntax in Vim.
Du musst, du musst irgendwie sagen, set Syntax?
Nee, oh fuck, ich weiß es nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Du kannst, also Syntax on kannst du sagen, aber das ist es ja nicht.
Ähm, Syntax on, ich musste ja sagen, welche, oder File, File Type.
File Type.
Kann ich sagen RS?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Syntax on.
Du kannst dem irgendwie sagen.
Ach hier, set file type. Das meine ich hier.
File type RS.
Geht nicht. Okay.
Geht nicht.
Geht Rust.
Rust geht. Okay.
Jetzt highlighten wir ihn.
Das sieht tatsächlich ganz sinnig aus, was das Ding hier macht.
Finde ich ganz gut, was das Model hier gemacht hat.
Das hat ganz schön krass gethinkt, ja.
GDU.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Das Ding ist, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht in allen...
Ich kann's hier mal angucken.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht in allen
Distributionen dabei, ja.
GDU.
Gauen wir mal.
Moment, ist das NC-DU rewritten in Rust?
Ah ne, in Go
Ich hab schon gedacht, weil es wird ja alles in Rust rewritten
Okay, das ist GDU
Das ist im Prinzip wie NC
Was ist der Vorteil davon jetzt?
Na klar, was sonst?
Was sonst?
Written in Rust, na klar.
Okay, G-E-G-Gudu.
G-Gudu.
Find ich gut.
Gefällt mir an sich.
Ist halt das gleiche wie NC-DU.
Das Ding ist jetzt nur...
Was hat das denn für Features
gegenüber...
Warum sollte ich das benutzen?
Das hat ein Webinterface.
Das hier oder was?
Wirklich?
Tatsächlich.
Minus Minus Web.
Hä?
Okay, das ist...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll.
Es ist irgendwie cool,
aber auch irgendwie useless.
Aber trotzdem, warum nicht?
Mit Go ist es halt easy, Webinterfaces
zu embedden.
Irgendwie ist es doch ganz
cool, oder?
Und kann man jetzt hier auch was mit machen?
Kann ich jetzt auch hier sagen,
die Datei will ich löschen oder so? Das geht
nicht. Man kann nur browsen. Löschen kann man hier drüber
nicht. Oder doch?
Ne, man kann hier nur
browsen drüber, nicht löschen.
trotzdem ganz witzig, ja.
Aber, aber warum ich,
warum ich es gegenüber NC-DU verwenden sollte,
Moment, NC-DU gibt es jetzt in SIG?
BTF.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen, langsam.
So, also, warum ich das,
warum ich NCDU mag, ist,
wir probieren jetzt mal was aus.
Docker run
Alma Linux 10.
Wir gucken mal, ob es das bei Red Hat gibt, okay?
Yam Update.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz eine Runde
Gedudel anmachen.
Nicht NCDU.
GDU. Ob es GDU gibt.
Yam Search
GDU.
Gibt es nicht. Siehste?
In Cedu weiß ich, dass es das gibt.
Ich habe das auf allen meinen Servern installiert.
Wenn ich in Cedu gesagt habe, dann ist es falsch.
Ich meine Gedu.
Siehste? Gibt es nicht. Das ist halt schon mal doof.
Deswegen kann ich das nicht verwenden.
Gibt es das denn auf
Debian
Trixi
Upt Update
Upt Search
Gedu
Ah ja, bei Debian
gibt es das. Das Problem ist,
alle meine Server auf der Arbeit,
99% meiner Server auf der Arbeit
sind Red Hat. Dementsprechend
gibt es kein GDU unter
Red Hat. Leider.
Hat mir jetzt eigentlich ganz gut gefallen, als Alternative.
ZG.
GDU kommt mit Apple?
Dann ist okay. Das muss ich jetzt gerade mal ausprobieren.
Das muss ich gerade mal ausprobieren. Moment.
Wie war das?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Yam, Install, Apple,
Repo oder irgendwie so.
Apple Release, genau.
Yum, Update.
Ups, jetzt habe ich auf No gedrückt.
Okay, yes.
Yum, Search, Gedu.
Das kommt mit Epal.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben es unter Debian, dementsprechend auch Ubuntu.
Und wir haben es unter Red Hat.
Dann ist das tatsächlich sogar eine ganz gute Alternative zu NCDU.
Ah, es gibt es nicht auf Alpine.
Na gut, auf Alpine brauche ich das nicht.
Ja.
Du meinst, Jump
Provides ist besser als
Search, oder was?
Es ist vor allem langsamer als Surge.
Ja, geil.
Was ist jetzt der Vorteil davon?
Außer, dass es langsamer ist?
Oder jetzt ist es aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
War Diver.
Jam macht Jam Dinger.
Achso
Ja ich such sonst immer hier
What ist das das gleiche
What provides
Das mach ich sonst immer
Ist das das gleiche
Wie provides
Okay
Man lernt nicht aus
Das ist tatsächlich aber eine ganz gute
Ganz gute Alternative
Das Ding ist aber bloß
Warum sollte ich gedu verwenden
Wenn ich ncdu habe
Und das einfach auch funktioniert
und das gleiche macht.
Ah.
Aber gut zu wissen.
Excellent. Guck mal weiter.
Ding, minus, minus Web.
Ja.
Weil ich das auf meinen Surfern unbedingt brauche.
Webview. Ich komm da nicht mal hin.
Da muss ich irgendwie SSH-Tunneling
Späße machen, dass ich da
an das Webinterface komme.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
wie er uns Beethoven schmackhaft machen will.
Ich bin kein Fan von Btop. Btop ist total, wie soll man sagen, so total over the top.
Ja, und das Interface versteht halt keiner.
Ja, Quick ist mit Btop schon mal gar nichts. Da blickst du nicht durch.
Bei diesem Menü kriege ich auch Anfälle.
Also keine Ahnung.
B-Top ist echt nicht meins.
H-Top Goat.
Wie ich jetzt wusste, dass er auch eine LS-Alternative drin hat.
Kommt mir auch nicht in die Tüte.
Ja, ich weiß, diese Tools sind an sich ganz cool.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es jetzt seht.
Ja, habe ich.
So, guck, haben wir schon das erste Problem. Hast du schon das erste Problem? Es ist nicht kompatibel zu LS. Das heißt, würde ich das jetzt setzen als Alternative zu LS, müsste ich immer umlernen, wenn ich auf dem Server bin versus ich bin lokal. Das ist der Grund, warum ich es nicht verwende.
an sich, ja, warum nicht
ja, es sieht ein bisschen
schöner aus, guck
hier, das versus
das
aber
es ist jetzt nicht so, als wäre
das hier irgendwie unreadable
was ich schön finde
das hat der Ex da damals auch, was ich hier ganz schön finde
ist die Anzeige von den Benutzerberechtigungen
du kannst ja
einen Alias setzen, doch
wenn ich ein alias setze
siehst du doch hier
der kann die ls Parameter nicht
also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sage
alias ls
gleich eza
und ich sag jetzt ls
ls minus lacht
dann geht es nicht
deswegen kommt mir dieses Ding nicht in die Tüte
So, next.
Mal gucken, wie Raus das schmackhaft machen will.
Also, ich muss jetzt nochmal dazu sagen,
diese Tools sind alle nicht übel, ne?
Also, wenn ihr Entwickler seid
und ihr wollt irgendwie einen besonders effektiven Workflow
oder Tools, die euch einfach nur Spaß machen und gefallen,
auf eurer Entwicklungskiste haben
und ihr seid nicht regelmäßig auf Servern unterwegs,
könnt ihr das alles benutzen.
Dann ist es für euch ja egal,
dass es auf dem Server sich irgendwie anders benutzt.
Ihr habt damit wahrscheinlich eh nicht viel zu tun.
Könnt ihr machen.
Genauso die Leute, die sich ihre Shell super krass customizen mit Oh My Cish und sowas.
Kann man alles machen.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben, aber kann man alles machen, wenn es nur um lokale Bedienung geht.
Gar kein Problem.
Wie gesagt, kommt mir nicht in die Tüte, weil nicht kompatibel CLI-Interface-technisch zu LS.
Wir müssen mal schauen, hat denn das vielleicht ein...
...ein...
...Kompatibilitätsmodus?
Anscheinend nicht.
Was?
Ne, gibt's anscheinend nicht.
Oder, Chad, wie ist es bei euch?
Was sagt ihr?
Also ich meine, ihr könnt jetzt hier, mal zur Auswahl, hier oben ist LS-LA oder hier LS-LA und hier unten ist ESA-LA. Ist das da unten so viel besser, dass das Umlernen sich lohnt und die Probleme in den Kauf zu nehmen, dass man auf dem Server sich vertippt?
Also ich finde nicht. Ich finde die LS-Ausgabe ist vollkommen fein.
Ja, die Benutzer... Am coolsten finde ich die Benutzerberechtigung mit den Color Codes für die Benutzerberechtigung.
Das finde ich schon sehr praktisch.
Die Color Codes für die Benutzerberechtigung. Das finde ich wirklich nice hier unten.
Aber der Rest ist jetzt nicht so, als hättest du es unbedingt gebraucht.
Das habe ich ein paar mal probiert.
Max, diese Alias-Dinger, ich komme damit nicht klar.
Zumal es auf Servern halt auch nicht gesetzt ist.
Kann man sich das Color-Coding nicht auch irgendwie anders basteln?
Doch, bestimmt. Aber das hast du auch auf Servern nicht verfügbar.
Wie gesagt, mir geht es bei diesen Standard-Tools immer darum, dass ich zur Hälfte der Zeit des Tages per SSH auf irgendwelchen Linux-Servern bin.
Und wenn ich mich daran gewöhne, dass man irgendwas auf eine spezielle Art gewöhne und dann geht das auf Server nicht oder umgedreht, ist halt kacke.
ist GPing.
Und das ist einer der einfachsten
Netzwerktools, die wir haben.
Lass mich raten.
Wenn GPing, ist Ping
rewritten in Rust? Klingt ein bisschen
nach Go, aber
wegen G?
Es ist written in Rust!
Fuck! Sogar Ping
ist rewritten in Rust mittlerweile!
Ich fass es nicht!
Ping!
Und es hat irgendeinen krassen Graf dabei.
Okay, Moment.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
G-Ping.
Hat schon irgendjemand mal gepingt und sich gedacht?
Fuck, Alter.
Ich würde es ja gerne öfters benutzen,
aber es ist nicht written in Rust.
Ich kann Ping einfach nicht benutzen.
Okay, guck mal mal.
G-Ping.
ETF.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Ich finde die Ping-Ausgabe besser als das.
Ping-Ausgabe hast du einfach schwarz auf weiß, was Sache ist.
Und hier musst du immer gucken, ah, was hatten wir hier denn?
Ganz ehrlich, die Ping-Ausgabe ist sogar übersichtlicher.
Du kannst dir einfach angucken, okay, was waren die letzten 10 Pings?
Klar.
Es ist schon cool, dass es das gibt.
Ich will jetzt keinem irgendwie das das das das mag ich machen, dass er das entwickelt oder so.
Das macht bestimmt Bock, das hat bestimmt seinen Anwendungszweck, aber
ich weiß nicht, wofür ich es verwenden sollte.
Schau mal mal, schau mal mal, wie uns das schmackhaft machen will.
Much more interesting.
Now, traditionally, the Pink Man is the first networking troubleshooting tool
that you learn in any operating system and it can immediately tell you
if a host is responding, what the latency looks like and all those network specifics.
Jetzt G-Ping nimmt das Daten und grafft es direkt in den Terminal.
Es ist einfach mit App installiert.
G-Ping-Y und anstatt gegen den Host zu pinnen,
kannst du einfach nur G-Ping 10.1.149.10 als Beispiel machen.
Und du kannst die Latenz über die Zeit schauen.
Und ich denke, das wird wirklich nützlich,
besonders wenn du eine unstable Netzwerkkonnexion, ISP,
finde ich nicht.
Ich finde die normale Ping Ausgabe in dem Fall ist viel übersichtlicher und besser.
... oder sogar einen Art von Konnexion mit verschiedenen Teilen deines Labor.
Du kannst auch mehrere Hosts überwinden.
Was hat der da links eigentlich für komisches Gedöns da am Start?
Was ist denn das für ein Terminal?
Ist das Konsole?
Ghosty?
Oder was ist das?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine nicht, dass man das bräuchte mit dem Host View.
Terminux.
What?
Was für ein Ding?
Termux.
Ne, das ist für Android, oder?
Android
keine Ahnung was er da hat
okay, das ist praktisch
ja
das kann man machen
ich hab auch mal eine Weile meine Shell
ähm, Config auf Server gesynct
ähm
das geht ich weiß ich weiß aber nicht wie einfach das ist wir müssen hier bei
den ssh proxy drüber weiß gar nicht ob das da geht das habe ich auch eine
weile gemacht
miyos github
thermos
das ist schieft
CLI for SSH client terminus.
Is closed and pay.
Ganz ehrlich, but why?
Westterm, beste was es gibt.
Okay, aber das was er jetzt gezeigt hat, das fand ich tatsächlich ganz nice.
Da kannst du mehrere Server pingen, ja.
Und siehst dann, 4.4.4 gibt es nicht.
Ernsthaft?
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht?
Gibt es 2.2.2?
Auch nicht.
9.9.9?
Okay, das gibt's.
Das finde ich in der Tat tatsächlich schon mal ganz cool wieder.
Da siehst du jetzt nämlich hier den Unterschied,
ob du bei einem richtig krasse Ausreißer hast.
Ja, sieht nicht gut aus.
Das finde ich dann aber schon wieder,
dafür finde ich es schon wieder ganz sinnvoll.
Aber für einzelne IPs
finde ich die Ping-Ausgabe viel, viel besser.
Die Ausgabe hier ist cool,
wenn man Hackermans Zeug zeigen will.
Wenn jemand bei euch auf den Bildschirm guckt
Und ihr wollt Hackerman mäßig aussehen
Dann ist das geil, wenn man das hier so hat
Und dann am besten unten noch den hier
Und hier nebenbei noch Asciiquarium
Zack
Ist das mal nicht krasser Hackerkrempel, ey
Stimmt.
Und noch Hardtop an.
Jawohl.
Excellent.
Timmy, Timmy!
Nicht wegschwimmen!
Okay.
Irgendwie dachte ich mir auch, dass das kommt.
Verwende ich übrigens aus dem gleichen Grund nicht.
Wie alles andere.
Das ist so ein automatisch lernendes CD.
Ich kenn das, ich kenn das.
Es ist nicht, dass ich nicht wüsste, was es ist.
in der show so vorbeischneiden sorgzeit an den bash to your bach rc file and once
outside has seen you visit ja doch du musst dich umgewöhnen weil die funktionalität mit
diesem es springt nach home das normale cd gar nicht kann das heißt du bist auf dem server
drauf willst cd machen sagt cd home und wo das nicht warum es nicht funktioniert
Test. It's like 15 layers deep
within another directory in the home directory.
I can just simply type z-test
and then Zoxide figures out
that that's where I want to go.
And that becomes super useful and it gets better
as you use this tool over time
because it, again, it learns all of those
directories that you're visiting day in and day out.
Now, one nice thing about this entire
collection of tools is that on Debian or
Ubuntu, you can simply install
nearly all of them in just a single shot.
I can first run app to update.
Ach, jetzt habe ich das verstanden, wie das funktioniert.
Das hängt sich irgendwie in CD rein oder überschreibt CD und mit Z kann man dann springen.
Das heißt, das normale CD funktioniert wie gehabt.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Ja gut, das wissen wir, wie das funktioniert.
still von augen will ja wie gesagt vor allem wenn man auf servern unterwegs ist
es halt für mich wichtig dass das halt so funktioniert wie es erwartet
find and cd all of the time so for practical for many of us today with
linux either in our homeland before so if you haven't tried these before i
would pick okay waren tatsächlich hubs waren tatsächlich ganz gute empfehlung
dabei auch wir haben die hälfte geschafft 52 minuten noch leute der
download geht schneller jetzt so lange bin ich wahrscheinlich nicht mehr aber
mal gucken schauen und ganz wichtig wir haben vor drei stunden updates gemacht
wir sind unter art schien uns bei the way
na klar na klar
na klar gibt es gibt updates
Was ich über lokale KI gelernt habe.
Moment, wollten wir nicht das Video von Woffers?
Haben wir vorher nicht geguckt.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran,
dass ich es über Extras installiert habe.
Und in dem Extras Cache Repo ist noch eine neuere Version drin.
Deswegen hat er das jetzt geupdatet.
Tja, keine Ahnung, was mein LM-Studio da wiederum spinnt.
Ich dachte nicht, dass ein normales HTTP-Get irgendwo heutzutage noch langsam sein kann.
Aber keck wie JavaScript, sag ich nur.
So, was haben wir hier? Was ich über lokale KI gelernt habe?
Hopp. Hopp.
Was hat er denn gelernt? Was los?
Okay, das ist tatsächlich, das gucken wir uns an.
Wie gut sind lokale Models?
Der hat da bestimmt mehr ausprobiert als ich.
Und das gab es ja auch vorhin als Frage im Stream, was der Unterschied ist.
Also ob die Unterschiede immer noch so groß sind.
Kapitel 1, wie gut sind die lokalen Modelle genau?
Also woher weiß man das überhaupt, wie gut die Modelle sind?
Woher ich das weiß? Also aus praktischer Erfahrung, weil ich sage ja seit Wochen spiele ich mit den Dingern rum.
Boah, ey, was das Ding kostet, hä? Das sind Mac Studios, oder? Mac Studios mit Dings. Also, die sind aktuell echt nicht billig.
Aber das zeigen auch die beiden Websites Artificial Analysis und Arena AI.
Die ranken Modelle anhand unterschiedlicher Kriterien, welche das sind, sage ich später noch dazu.
Aber auf jeden Fall finden sich hier in den Rankings auf beiden Seiten eigentlich immer die Modelle von Entropic vorne.
Also Cloth Opus 5 oder Fable 5.
Aber...
Okay, ja.
Warum ist denn Cloud Opus 5 High höher als Max?
Während früher dahinter eigentlich immer OpenAI mit GPT-Modellen kam
und Google-Modelle, also Google Gemini,
Fanden sich da in den letzten Wochen immer wieder Modelle von Alibaba, die machen die Qen-Modelle, ZAI, die haben GLM oder Moonshot AI, die haben Kimi im Programm.
Ach stimmt, die habe ich ja schon komplett verdrängt wieder. Kimi gibt es ja auch noch.
Zurzeit zum Beispiel auf Platz 5 bei Artificial Analysis von allen getesteten Modellen.
Ja und alle drei Firmen kommen aus China und alle diese Modelle sind sogenannte Open-Rates-Modelle, die man runterladen und selbst laufen lassen kann.
Also, wenn man die Hardware hat.
So, und ich muss zugeben, dass ich lange Zeit eher so ein bisschen der Skeptiker war und dachte, ja gut, die lokalen Modelle, die mögen in den Benchmarks ganz gut abschneiden manchmal, aber in der Praxis kommen die doch eh nicht an die Qualität der großen US-Anbieter ran.
Und dann muss ich auch sagen, da war ich auch ein bisschen irritiert, als ich den Analysten und Podcaster Pip Klöckner gesehen habe, der, wie ich finde, sehr kompetent über die wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge in der KI-Welt berichtet, als der vor ein paar Monaten Folgendes sagte.
Mit einem Zeitverzug von sechs bis sieben Monaten könnt ihr auf eurem Heim-PC eine KI nutzen, die so schlau ist, wie was vor einem halben Jahr in einem Datacenter laufen würde.
Ja und ich dachte mir damals, ja nee, sechs bis sieben Monate, das ist doch Wunschdenken, oder?
Aber ich habe dann jetzt mal selbst die Rechnung gemacht mit dem brandneuen Qen 3827B.
Und das Ding läuft ja auf jeden Fall auf einer Consumer Gaming Karte, auf einer High-End 24GB.
Würde ich ja auch laufen lassen.
Moin Michael, 5 Spiele an.
Karte 2, aber zum Beispiel auch auf einer RTX 3090 und die ist ja immerhin schon 6 Jahre alt und die kriegt man gebraucht eigentlich für unter 1000 Euro.
Das ist so krass, eine 6 Jahre alte Grafikkarte für 1000 Euro.
Hier auf Artificial Analysis bekommt das Modell einen Intelligence Score von 52.
Vor sieben Monaten waren die State-of-the-Art-Modelle Cloth Opus 4.5, Google Gemini 3 Pro und OpenAI GPT 5.2.
Ja, und alle diese Modelle werden mir hier mit weniger Punkten angezeigt.
Also okay, auf dem Papier, korrekt.
Aber kommen wir mal in die Praxis. Kann das denn wirklich stimmen?
Ja komm, wir fragen Qen3827B einfach mal Sachen.
Seit wann gibt's Heise Online? Wie hießen die ersten fünf Sams-Bücher?
Ja, und da kommt dann, ich sag's mal ganz deutlich, kompletter Schrott raus.
Also kennt ihr zum Beispiel die Fachzeit trifft Datenschnitt? Ja, nee, ich auch nicht. Und die gab es auch nie, natürlich. Und es gab auch kein Sams und Schnippel in Afrika. Ja, okay, aber was ist denn jetzt mit so einfacheren Sachen? Also Fakten, die definitiv sehr häufig im Trainingsmaterial gestanden haben. Gehe ich mal von aus.
Zum Beispiel, gib mir alle Bundespräsidenten der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Ja, und da sieht die Liste erstmal auf den ersten Blick okay aus, aber wenn man genauer hinguckt, sind da etliche Fehler drin.
Horst Köhler war zum Beispiel nicht in der FDP.
Und Karl Carstens ist auch nicht im Amt verstorben, sondern erst 1992.
Aber wie kann das jetzt sein, dass Quenn 3827b so viele Punkte im Intelligence-Ranking hat und so einen Mist erzählt?
Ja, ganz einfach, weil die meisten Benchmarks im Intelligence Index Ranking hier nicht das Wissen abfragen, sondern die überprüfen, wie gut die Modelle coden können, wie gut die ein Terminal bedienen können, wie gut die Werkzeuge wie Websuche bedienen können, wie exakt die sich einzelne Informationen in langen Prompts, in langen Kontexten merken können.
Reines Wissen fragt eigentlich nur noch einen Benchmark aus den neun hier in diesem Index Verwendeten ab.
Und das ist AA Omniscience, der zu 12 Prozent in diese Gesamtpunktzahl reingeht.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, hä, was ist das für ein Quatsch?
Nein, das ist wirklich sinnvoll, weil eben 2026 reines Wissen abfragen nicht mehr wirklich so relevant ist bei LLMs.
Denn LLMs können ja in so agentischen Systemen im Internet suchen.
Die müssen das ja alles gar nicht sehen.
Ja geil. Und im Internet finden sie dann Dinger, die selbst von KI generiert wurden. Ein Teufelskreis.
Und das ist auch das große Umdenken, was jetzt gerade passiert.
Vielleicht brauchen wir gar nicht diese Riesenmodelle, vielleicht reichen ja kleinere, die darauf optimiert sind, sich die Informationen selbst zu suchen.
Und dazu komme ich auch später nochmal im Detail beim Kapitel Software.
Aber jetzt erstmal Kapitel 2. Was braucht man für Hardware?
So, also wie kriegt man jetzt die...
Naja, im Prinzip brauchst du eine fette Grafikkarte oder...
Max.
Diese ganzen dollen lokalen Modelle zum Laufen.
Ja, typische CT-Antwort, kommt drauf an.
Fangen wir mal mit dem aktuellen besten lokalen Modell an.
Also mit dem besten Modell, das man theoretisch selbst laufen lassen kann.
Das ist Kimi K3.
Das ist hier im Ranking auf Platz 5 und hat nur 2 Punkte weniger als zum Beispiel Cloud 5 Fable.
Und ich hatte mir in den Kopf gesetzt, dieses Kimi K3 zum Laufen zu kriegen.
Ich hatte mir extra für dieses Riesen...
Boah, da stehen einige 10.000 Euro gerade, hä?
...Kette LLM von Apple 4 Mac Studio mit M3 Ultra ausgeliehen.
Zwei mit 512 GB Unified RAM und zwei mit 276 GB.
Ordentlich.
Kommen wir also auf 1,5 TB schnellen Speicher.
Und ja, reicht nicht für Kimika 3, denn mit nutzbarem Kontext braucht das 1,6 TB.
Und dann hat mir Hetzner noch einen Server mit 8x RTX 6000 mit jeweils 96 GB superschnellem VRAM zur Verfügung gestellt.
Also dann hat einer dieser Cluster 768 GB RAM.
Da hätte ich dann drei Stück von gebraucht.
Also ich hätte das Modell auf drei dieser Server auslagern müssen.
Hat erstmal im Rechenzentrum die Temperatur im Schnitt um 1 Grad erhöht.
Diese Kiste alleine.
768 GB mal 3, das hätte ausgereicht.
Nicht mal 2 hätten gereicht.
Und das ist jetzt mein Punkt.
Dieses höher, schneller, weiter, das funktioniert nicht so einfach in der KI-Welt.
Also klar, 768 GB auf schnellen Blackwell-NVIDIA-Karten, das ist praktisch.
Zum Beispiel kann ich da zumindest GLM 5.2 drauflaufen lassen.
Das braucht so ungefähr 450 GB Speicher.
Aber das ist halt laut Artificial Analysis nur zwei Punkte besser als QN3827B, was auf meiner 24 GB Grafikkarte läuft.
Aber kurzer Einschub, GLM 5.2 ist wirklich ein Extremkompetenzmodell.
Gefällt mir richtig gut, habe ich viel mitgemacht.
Mir gefällt auch unter anderem gut, dass es nicht so krass zensiert ist wie QN.
Schaut mal, das antwortet QN3827B, wenn ich frage, was 1989 am Tianmenplatz passiert ist.
Zu diesem Thema kann ich keine Informationen bereitstellen.
Und im Nachdenkprozess kann man auch deutlich sehen, über dieses sensible Thema darf ich nicht sprechen.
Aber man kann diese Zensur wirklich nicht für alle chinesischen Modelle verallgemeinern,
denn GLM 5.2, ja, ist auch aus China, antwortet ausführlich auf die Frage
und schlägt sogar von sich aus vor, mal drüber zu sprechen,
dass die chinesische Regierung seit Jahrzehnten versucht, das Massaker unter den Teppich zu kehren.
Ja, weil die Dinger halt O-Main sind, gibt es inzwischen auch angeblich unzensierte Modelle,
sogenannte obliterated modelle von quen aber das konnten wir bislang noch nicht ausprobieren wenn
euch das interessiert gerne in die kommentare schreiben sowie alle anderen fragen die ihr habt
alles gerne in die kommentare schreiben aber ja sind so hin und her gel m52 läuft auf jeden fall
nicht auf consumer hardware deshalb wieder zurück zu quen und hier gilt wie schon mehrfach erwähnt
quen 38 27 b funktioniert auf gpu ab würde ich ja würde ich ja auch gerne machen wenn er download
mal fertig wird. 24 GB oder auf Rechnern mit schnellem Unified Speicher, also zum Beispiel
AMD Strix Halo Maschinen, Nvidia RTX Sparks oder auf Apple Rechnern mit M Prozessor. Man muss
allerdings bedenken, dass man die 24 GB bei so Unified Geschichten wirklich frei haben muss.
Wenn der Rechner also insgesamt nur 24 GB hat, dann passt QN 27B nicht, weil das Betriebssystem
und sowas ja auch noch irgendwo untergebracht werden muss im Speicher. Und wenn ihr jetzt sagt,
Es gibt doch Quantisierung.
Also damit ist gemeint, dass die Genauigkeit der Werte in den Rates verringert wird.
Also dass die gerundet gespeichert werden.
Dadurch werden die Daten kleiner, passt besser in weniger Speicher.
Aber es ist sowieso inzwischen schon de facto Standard, dass Open Rates LLMs so im Bereich Q4, Q5, also 4 bis 5 Bit Quantisierung verwendet werden.
Weil genauere Daten bringen euch fast nichts.
Wahrscheinlich wäre der Download sogar im Internet Explorer schneller.
Wenn euch das interessiert.
Gibt es das Ding überhaupt noch?
Ne.
3-Bit, da sieht man schon Verschlechterung, aber über den Daumen kann man sagen, ab 4-Bit ist die Verschlechterung vernachlässigbar.
Zumindest beim Pelikan-Test hier, bei den Wissensbenchmarks kann man so ungefähr sagen, bricht es ab 5-Bit etwas ein.
Und ja, deshalb werden LLMs inzwischen meist in 4-5-Bit verwendet, weil Speicher verschwenden.
Das wollen wir alle nicht. Gerade heutzutage nicht.
Ja, das stimmt.
2026, wo zum ersten Mal Nachfolgegeräte von Handys oder Laptops rauskommen.
Ja, es gibt, die produzieren teilweise alte Sachen wieder.
Die weniger Speicher als die Vorgänger zum gleichen Preis bieten.
Also, niemand hat so viel Speicher.
Die meistverkaufte Grafikkarte zur Zeit ist ja die AMD RX9070XT mit 16 GB Videospeicher.
Und darauf könnt ihr die QN-Varianten mit der sogenannten Mixture-of-Experts-Technik verwenden.
Konkret ist das zum Beispiel QN3635BA3B.
Das ist ein griffiger Name.
Das Ding hat zwar mehr Parameter als das 27B-Modell, nämlich 35 Milliarden statt 27, aber wegen dieser MOE-Technik müssen die nicht alle gleichzeitig im GPU-Speicher sein, sondern nur die sogenannten Experten, die gerade verwendet werden.
Der Rest kann im langsamen System RAM rumhängen und deshalb läuft das auch auf 16 GB.
Leider gab es das während meiner Tests noch nicht in der 3.8. Version, sondern nur in 3.6.
Aber das hat auch okay 32 Punkte im Intelligenzindex von Artificial Analysis.
Und guckt mal, hier habe ich sogar Benchmark-Ergebnisse für euch von meinem Kollegen Danny Gille.
34,9 mit der 9060 XT und ungefähr 57 Token die Sekunde mit der Nvidia 5.
Ist trotzdem flott.
9060 Ti.
Eine 9060 XT mit 16 Gig, Achtung, die gibt es auch mit 8 Gigabyte Speicher, kostet, sagen wir mal, knapp 500 Euro.
Und ja, wenn ihr jetzt denkt, brauche ich denn überhaupt eine Grafikkarte, kann ich nicht den Hauptspeicher verwenden?
Ja, könnt ihr, aber das ist lahm.
Und ihr wollt gerade für Agenten, also wo es so viel hin und her geht, intern, eigentlich mindestens 30 Token die Sekunde haben.
Für die normale sogenannte Token Generation.
Wie viele Tokens hatten wir auf dem NAS nochmal? 8 oder so, gell? Mit der internen GPU und dem Model quasi nur in der SSD. Ich glaube 8 oder so, das war halt echt lahm. Aber immerhin, es lief auf dem NAS.
Mal Tokens, die generiert werden.
Agenten arbeiten dummerweise auch mit riesigen Prompts.
Das heißt dann, je größer die Prompt-Zulassung, also je größer der Kontext wird,
desto mehr Verarbeitungszeit brauchen die LLMs.
Und das machen GPUs einfach deutlich schneller.
Stichwort Prompt Processing.
Und da sind gerade Nvidia GPUs richtig gut drin.
Wenn ihr wirklich nur KI machen wollt, Agenten und so Kram,
und ihr in dem Bereich unter 2000 Euro für den Komplett-PC bleiben wollt,
dann würde ich euch eher eine gebrauchte RTX 3090 empfehlen.
Da könnt ihr dann nämlich dank 24 GB Grafikspeicher
Qen 3.8 27B verwenden.
Und das Ding funktioniert wirklich super mit OpenCore,
Hermes oder OpenCode oder sonst was.
Und da wären wir direkt in Kapitel 3 Software.
Ich hatte das ja schon gesagt,
die kleinen Modelle spielen ihre Stärken nur aus,
wenn sie Tools benutzen können.
Und dazu brauchen sie ein sogenanntes Harness, also Software drumherum, die regelt, was das LLM machen darf und was dem LLM zum Beispiel...
Ich habe eine ganze Weile Open Code verwendet, gerade weil die auch immer gute kostenlose Models hatten.
Ich bin da mittlerweile echt wieder ein bisschen von weg.
Aber wahrscheinlich, weil ich es auch nie so benutzt habe, wie es gedacht ist.
Diese Dinger sind ja dafür gedacht, dass du sagen kannst, ey, ich brauche jetzt das und das.
mach mal und dann lässt du die viertelstunde bis zu zwei tagen oder so laufen und guckt was rauskommt
das habe ich nie gemacht also ich habe nie wie es erweitern ist ja auch heutzutage nennt man das ja
agentic engineering ermöglicht eben im internet was bin kein guter agent agentic engineer zu
schlagen und in terminal zu benutzen und programme zu starten um zum beispiel mit peyton irgendwas
auszurechnen und solche harnisse gibt es etliche inzwischen also rund um die uhr agentische
Systeme, die die ganze Zeit laufen, wie OpenClaw und Hermes, hatten wir zu beiden schon ein Video,
oder auch so On-Demand-Coding-Tools, also nicht immer laufen, sondern die ich manuell aufrufe
und denen ich dann einfach in echter Sprache sage, was sie tun sollen. Die können auch Sachen
auf meinem Rechner machen, also sowas wie, keine Ahnung, ordne mir mal die Bilder in diesem Ordner,
Software XY läuft hier nicht richtig, kannst du mal in den Logs gucken oder so. Und das funktioniert
wirklich erstaunlich gut, müsst ihr echt mal ausprobieren. Das ist, ja, das ist cool. Ja,
Ich nutze im Moment auf jeden Fall sehr gerne Open Code und da ziehe ich mir ein lokales LLM rein und dann kann das tolle Dinge tun.
Und ich nutze das alles gerne auf der Kommandozeile.
Wenn ihr das partout nicht wollt, also ich würde es euch empfehlen eigentlich, aber wenn ihr das nicht wollt, dann könntet ihr zum Beispiel das neue LM Studio Bionic verwenden.
Das unterstützt auch Toolcalls und auch Websuche.
Was mir allerdings nicht so gut gefällt, will man die Websuche bei LM Studio Bionic aktivieren, muss man erst ein Account erstellen.
Moment.
Das heißt, LM Studio, was ich hier
erzählt habe, ist outdated, oder was?
Weil ich hab LM Studio
und es gibt jetzt was Neues, oder was?
Oder wie?
Aha.
Geil.
Und was ist mit dem alten LM Studio?
0, 4, 2, 3.
Das ist aber auch... Hä?
Ja, wie jetzt?
Ach, das ist wieder...
Das ist was anderes.
Mein Download ist timed out, wirklich?
Oh!
Please try to resume.
Oh, jetzt flutscht es, Leute.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Oder auch nicht.
Es wird schon wieder langsamer.
Wackelkontakt, Leute.
MonkaS.
Wackelkontakt.
Wackelos.
So, jetzt.
Jetzt wieder okay.
Aber wenigstens macht er hier weiter.
Das Dolle an lokalen Modellen, dass ich eben keinen Account irgendwo habe und Daten bei irgendeiner Firma hinterlasse.
Ich finde aber...
Aber jetzt hört es wieder okay an, alles ganz normal, ne?
Sowieso immer ganz elegant, wenn man das LLM und den Harness voneinander trennt.
Also ich stelle mir das LLM immer so wie Wasser vor, was aus einem Wasserhahn kommt.
Und ihr könnt da dann halt unterschiedliche Dinge dran anschließen.
an den Wasserhahn. Also ein Duschkopf
oder ein Rasensprenger.
Keine Ahnung, eine Wasserbombe. Weiß ich nicht.
Der Wasserhahn heißt auf jeden Fall in der
KI-Sprache Endpoint. Und
diesen Endpoint stellt die sogenannte
Runtime oder die LLM
Engine, KI-Engine zur Verfügung.
Also die Software, die die LLM
gewickelt und die...
Das wissen wir ja schon.
Guck mal, jetzt geht's auf einmal
zackig.
Hoffen wir mal das bleibt so.
Aber dann sonst noch hier.
Was verbirgt WhatsApp?
Massive Hack.
Was ist das?
Entweder übernimmt die...
Weiß nicht, irgendwie nix dabei.
Chat, ich muss mal kurz mein Handy holen.
Ich muss gucken, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Ja.
Open Code im Container.
Ich hab...
Also ich hab das auch schon
Ich hab das auch schon auf dem
Host
Auf dem Host laufen lassen
Aber ich entwickle ja Sachen nur noch
Im Container, also zum Beispiel
Gehen wir jetzt mal hier
Gehen wir jetzt mal hier rein, nehmen wir mal irgendwie das
Wo wir das letzte Mal drin rumgebastelt haben
Irgendwie da
So
Äh, falsch, wo muss ich hin
an die nicht aufwendig muss zu heiß hier ein champ
jetzt baut er sich ein container zusammen das dauert jetzt beim
erstmaligen starten ein bisschen länger baut sich ein container zusammen für
das projekt startet auch gleich eine idee für das projekt lockt sich per command line ein in
dem container und da habe ich dann auch ein code drauf das heißt es läuft im container und in dem
container ist nicht mein haus docker proxy gemap ja oder sonstige größt großartige sachen weil
hauptsächlich mache ich das dass ich nicht so anfällig bin für supply chain attacks
Das ist ja mittlerweile omnipräsent überall.
Ja, sei es jetzt Python-Packages, Rust-Packages, C-Sharp-Packages, JavaScript-Packages,
Supply Chain Attack wird ja mittlerweile überall.
Und das kann ich ein bisschen eindämmen, indem jetzt der Container hier wenigstens keinen Zugriff auf meine SSH-Keys und sowas hat.
Das hier muss ich nur einmal machen.
Einmal beim Projekt starten wird der Container gebaut.
guckt du siehst schon ich habe jetzt auf den container habe ich jetzt hier ist
hier im container dann daten irgendwann auch noch mal idee genau idee und open
code im container genau so als startet die idee gleich irgendwann mal fast so
auf Desktop 3.
Ah ja.
Fuck. Okay, Leute.
Ähm.
Ich müsste die...
Okay, Trial.
Bam.
Excellent.
Trial gestartet.
Oh, dann geht die EDE auf.
Wie gesagt, beim ersten Mal dauert das alles ein bisschen länger.
Weil
das ist für den halt wie wenn
das zum ersten mal installiert hast und auch die ganzen tools und so müssen
geupdatet werden deswegen braucht es ein bisschen so aber ich sage im endeffekt
hier app source an die das die python app go jetzt habe ich was aufgemacht
null wie auch immer hier habe ich hier habe ich jetzt das ganze zeug drin und
hier habe ich meine command line kam da kann ich dann auch hingehen und kann
dann sagen hier keine ahnung
mal ein Go-App.
Kann ich hier reingehen und sagen,
wann.
Geht jetzt allerdings nicht,
weil ich den Stick nicht dran habe.
Aber ihr seht, das funktioniert.
Geht jetzt nicht, weil kaputt.
Invalid Memory Address, bla bla.
Jaja. Aber hier kann ich starten.
Kannst du mit IntelliJ im Dev-Container
debuggen?
Ja, kann ich.
Weil
der installiert einen Agent,
also so einen JetBrains-Agent
im Container. Die IDE selbst
läuft lokal. Das heißt, die ist auch schnell hier.
Gar kein Problem.
Ja, die ist zackig.
Die haben hier im Hintergrund, siehst du hier?
Siehst du hier, läuft
hier Remote.
JetBrains Remote DevServer.
Darüber kommuniziert das Ding
im Container. Da kannst du auch
debuggen.
So.
Und hier hast du den Container und alles mögliche, kannst Zeug trimmern und da habe ich auch Open Code am Start.
Kann ich Open Code starten?
Und das dann fragen, keck w, größer lul w, Fragezeichen.
Und dann hoffen wir mal, das sagt mir jetzt irgendwie eine sinnvolle Antwort.
Alter, dieser Wackelkontakt ist echt abartig.
Keck W größer 0 W ist ein acceptable take.
Alles klar.
Tschätke?
Ist diese Session lokal?
Oder könnt ihr jetzt auch in diese Session drauf zugreifen?
Ne, okay. Das ist nur lokal.
Das mappt mir auch meine Open-Code-Config in den Container.
Wobei es kann sein, dass ich das rausgenommen habe.
Es sieht für mich sogar ein bisschen so aus, als hätte ich das rausgenommen.
Weil ich meine selbst konfigurierten Modes nicht mehr habe.
Ich habe das rausgenommen, weil ich Open-Code schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr benutzt habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe das rausgenommen.
Das wird zwar noch installiert, aber keine Config mehr dafür und sowas.
Ja, und wenn ich fertig entwickeln bin, kann ich einfach sagen, DevPod delete, bam, und zack ist das ganze rückstandslos wieder weg.
Doch, ich benutze DevPod, es gibt ein Fork von DevPod.
Moment.
Es gibt einen Fork.
Von dem hier.
Guck, der hat das geforkt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber der updatet es immer noch.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Ab und zu mal.
Also das ist
benutzbar.
Ich wollte auch mal sein neues Projekt ausprobieren.
Vielleicht ist das sogar noch die bessere Variante.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumal es 6-7 Sterne hat.
Musst du dich im Container Open Code neu einloggen?
Nee, ich mach das so.
Ich zeig's dir.
Warte mal.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das noch drinne hab.
Ja?
Warte mal.
Ich hab hier...
Guck mal.
Ich mappe mir meine
OpenCode-Config
in den Container.
Das heißt, alles, was da drin steht,
habe ich im Container.
Vielleicht habe ich die auch mittlerweile gelöscht oder so,
weil ich habe da eigentlich Custom-Modes
drin definiert,
die jetzt eben nicht da waren.
Also vielleicht habe ich sogar hier den Kram wieder gelöscht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe OpenCode eine ganze...
Ne, ich habe OpenCode hier noch gar nicht drauf verwendet.
Aber installiert habe ich es hier.
Okay.
Ich habe OpenCode hier noch gar nicht drauf verwendet.
Das hatte ich nur
auf der alten VM.
Hier habe ich, deswegen ist da auch noch gar nichts drin.
Und auf dem Host brauche ich es eh nicht mehr.
Aber du kannst ja das einfach reinmappen.
Das funktioniert.
Und für den ganzen Kram, dass ich das nicht immer neu einrichten muss, habe ich hier ein paar Templates.
Ich habe Templates für Java-Projekte, für Rust-Projekte, für Go und für Python-Projekte, für .NET.
Da kann ich dann im Endeffekt einfach nur hier sagen,
Templates, keine Ahnung,
templates go zum beispiel sage ich neuer projektname keck w0 w so und dann template
der mir das hier raus dann gehe ich hier rein und kann dann einfach sagen das ist das ist das
ist nur ein rapper ja das ist das ist nur ein rapper das macht nichts anderes wie diese dev
container connection skript aufzurufen das connection skript verbindet sich auf den
konnte ja sagt hat er das geklont jetzt sage ich okay das ist ein go projekt
schrieg online starten jetzt muss halt initial einmal den container bilden und
dann die idee starten und der container setzt sich zusammen aus guck mal hier
templates base ersten docker file der container jason asten docker fall dass
das base docker fall das ist bei allen meinen projekten immer gleich und dann
gibt es ein dann gibt es ein docker file
dann gibt es ein docker file pro springt falsch
ein docker file pro projekt so was er noch macht das ist wegen den supply
chain angriffen ja deswegen habe ich angefangen nur noch im container zu
entwickeln. Guck, ich habe jetzt ein neues Projekt,
ein neues Go-Projekt geklont.
Der hat jetzt initial einmal den Container gebaut,
hat da alles rein installiert, was wir für ein Go-Projekt
brauchen.
Startet jetzt die Go-IDE
und dann hast du hier alles am Start,
was du brauchst.
Wie gesagt, erster Start dauert ein bisschen, weil
er den ganzen Container und das ganze Zeug neu initialisieren
muss. Aber dann
funktioniert es so wie
lokal auch. Also da ist jetzt kein großer
also kein Geschwindigkeitsunterschied
eigentlich. Die Jetbrains-Dinger
sind alle jetzt nicht sonderlich schnell.
So.
Zack.
Muss ich halt das richtige
Projektverzeichnis öffnen.
Workspaces.
App.
This Window.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier eine Go-App.
Können wir rumprogrammieren.
dran.
Haben hier auch schon so ein paar Standardsachen drinnen.
Ja, wir haben ein Build-Script, ein Run-Script.
Wenn ich das jetzt runnen lasse,
dann führt er halt meine Hello World
App standardmäßig aus.
Und kompiliert einmal Go.
Und jetzt kann ich anfangen.
Also ich habe quasi jetzt einmal so komplett
raus getemplated,
wie ich es gerne hätte.
Und immer wenn ich jetzt noch ein neues
Go-Projekt anlegen will, clone ich mir einfach das Template.
Ah, man hat auch ein kleiner Docker-File schon drin zum Bauen.
Hattest du dir eigentlich den Code von Gwen kopiert?
Den hier?
Nee, warum?
Achso, doch, hatte ich, hatte ich.
Warum, fragst du?
Du meinst, ob ich das später noch, falls ich das später noch brauche?
Ja, schauen wir mal.
So, und wenn man fertig ist, das ist halt das Gute, ne?
Wenn man fertig ist, also siehst du, ich hab jetzt hier...
Achso, na gut, das ist ja plötzlich.
Hier kann ich nicht gucken.
Docker Images.
Hier, guck, hier ist der Container.
Der ist halt schon ein paar Gigabyte groß.
Und jetzt kann ich einfach sagen...
Devport, Delete, zack.
Und jetzt hab ich alles wieder gelöscht, was zu dem Projekt gehört.
kann das projekt nur den source code liegen lassen na ja so sieht das so wie das bei mir aus jetzt
muss ich unbedingt mal gucken was die mikrowelle macht was macht eigentlich mein download gerade
mal zwischendurch ist schon ziemlich erzielt ich lasse es jetzt gleich im hintergrund was
weiter downloaden.
So.
Haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir gucken können?
Irgendwas Spannendes?
Das ist natürlich, glaube ich,
total overengineert im Endeffekt.
Schauen wir mal.
Wir schauen uns mal, was YouTube hier empfiehlt.
Hier habe ich ja noch so gut wie nie YouTube offen gehabt.
Mal gucken, da kommt jetzt der ganze Schwachsinn, der in Deutschland so empfohlen wird.
Was auch immer.
nochmal updaten. Arch, by the way.
Was?
Sauerei.
Haben wir sonst hier noch irgendwas,
was wir Spannendes gucken können?
Das juckt doch alles.
Warum Offenbach boomt?
Warum boomt denn bitte schön Offenbach?
Bestimmt nicht wegen Haftbefehl.
Frankfurt, Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton Store, zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Stop making these five Homelab mistakes.
Okay, wir gucken uns das Video nicht an, wir gucken einfach...
Rackmount, ja Rackmount brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Bad Storage Layout
Cheap Network
No Documentation
No Documentation ist das Beste
Untested Backup
Oh man
Das ist irgendwie nicht so
Wisst ihr, was ich letztens gesehen habe?
Auch richtig hängen geblieben
Linux from Scratch
Speedrun
Guck mal
Linux vom Scratch Speedrun.
Neuer Weltrekord.
Natürlich in der 4M.
Was sonst? Ja, logisch.
Guck ich euch mal vor allem diese Tastatur an,
die er hier am Start hat.
Ist das eine Ducky-Tastatur?
Die sieht so ein bisschen von den Farben her so aus.
Aber ich könnte...
Also ganz ehrlich, ich würde mit so einer Tastatur
absolut null gar nicht klarkommen.
Da ist nix automatisiert oder per Makro.
Der tippt alles selbst.
So, gleich geht's.
Sobald das Slackware-System gestartet ist, geht's ab.
Alles von Hand, Alter
Das ist schon fast ASMR-Content
Linux vom Scratch Speedrun.
Also, vielleicht wollt ihr jetzt, dass ich euch erkläre, was er da macht.
So schnell kann ich nicht gucken und ich bin mir da auch nicht ganz sicher, ob ich checke, was er da macht, ja.
Ne, ich checke ehrlich gesagt nicht, was er macht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er da treibt.
Du meinst, dass Tastatur ist KI?
Crap-Config?
Kann sein!
Jetzt wird libc runtergeladen.
Wäre schon rein-taped, bevor die Kommandos eigentlich fertig sind.
Alles statisch kompilieren.
T-Mox beste hier.
Busybox Source Code.
Kann das sein, dass das noch viel schneller gehen würde, wenn sein Rechner nicht so ausgelastet wäre?
Ich glaube, sein Rechner ist ganz schön ausgelastet.
Ich würde sagen, der braucht einen PlaySyncly Fast 24-Kerne-Rechner, damit er noch schneller Linux from scratch machen kann.
Es geht ja darum, Linux from scratch nicht Arch zu installieren.
Arch Speedruns gibt es auch.
Arch Install Speedruns.
Ja, kenne ich.
Herder.
Habe ich aber noch nie ausprobiert.
Kenne ich nur aus Videos.
Und wie gesagt, ich bin ja eigentlich auch weg von Temux.
Ich benutze lokale Terminal Splits.
Gut, das geht jetzt da nicht.
Und Temux halt immer nur auf dem Server.
Oh, hat sich vertippt, Leute.
Zeitverlust.
Oh.
Noch mehr Zeitverlust.
Kein Negativ-Split hier.
Die Splits fehlen noch, oder?
Splits, dann wäre das noch mehr Professional Speedrun Content.
So, jetzt wird er gleich Crup installieren.
Vermute ich mal.
Oder einen EFI-Boot-Eintrag.
Einen EFI-Boot-Eintrag erstellen?
Nee, eh nicht RAMFS hin kopieren, oder?
Oder?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich blick's nicht.
Ja, Splits fehlen da eindeutig.
So, da unten wird jetzt Busybox
Busybox kompiliert. Unten rechts, glaube ich.
Das da oben ist die Kernel.
Also oben kompiliert er den Kernel, rechts kompiliert er Busybox.
Links hat er
Musel kompiliert vorhin und jetzt
will er irgendwie
Booteinträge
erstellen oder so.
Okay, Achtung.
Reboot-Time.
Max, was sagst du eigentlich
zum Aufreger-Thema der Woche?
Was ist das Aufreger-Thema der Woche?
Wahrscheinlich ist Time,
wenn Busybox
gestartet ist.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, er hätte noch Splits machen müssen.
Zucker, Zuckersteuer aufgedreht.
Die können mich mal alle, ey, mit ihrem Scheiß.
Überall sollst du mir Geld bezahlen, Mann.
Geht mir so auf den Sack.
Soll mir meine Kohle,
Soll meine Kohle in Ruhe lassen.
Der muss noch bis 20...
Okay, warte mal.
Ich will das Video...
Ich will nur mal kurz gucken, ob man ein paar Bilder sieht von...
Wie outdated, overrated das Zeug von der Bahn ist.
Sieht man da irgendwas?
Ein paar Bildschirme oder so?
Ich habe gedacht, man sieht noch was mit Windows 3.11 oder so drauf.
Ja, irgendwie heute nichts sonderlich Spannendes.
432 Sicherheitslücken in zwei Tagen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich KI-Stelz, ne?
KI repariert das Raid.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich, wenn mein Raid wirklich kaputt wäre
und da wären wichtige Sachen drauf, die ich unbedingt
von runter kriegen müsste, bin ich mir nicht so sicher,
ob ich die KI reparieren lassen würde.
Das macht die Mikrowelle noch nichts.
Bist du jetzt auch Hater?
Ja, so muss das auch sein.
Ja klar, die Leute, die nie Bahn fahren, die denken sich ja immer, so schlimm kann das doch gar nicht sein.
Und dann müssen sie selbst mal fahren und dann merken sie, dass das doch so schlimm ist.
Ja, habe ich schon gesehen.
Nudeln mit Lachs, heute gibt es kein Nudeln mit Lachs.
Heute gibt es Reis mit Hackfleischbällchen.
Echtes Hackfleisch, kein veganes Hackfleisch.
Letzte Woche hatte ich veganes
Spaghetti Bolognese hatte ich letzte Woche
glaube mit veganem Hackfleisch
Ich bin ja so Teilzeit Veganer mittlerweile
Also
Ich achte drauf weniger
Fleisch zu futtern
Aber
Nicht unbedingt
Nur
Das Tierwohls zu liebe
Ich hab mal
Irgendwann einen Artikel drüber gelesen
zu viel Fleisch essen erhöht das Darmkrebsrisiko.
Und seitdem versuche ich weniger Fleisch und mehr Veganes zu futtern.
Oder Vegetarisches auch zu futtern.
Also beispielsweise auf der Arbeit in der Kantine
hole ich mir eigentlich mittlerweile fast immer einen Salat
und oder das vegane, schrägstrich vegetarische Gericht.
Kann ich auch, aber man kann ja auch beides machen.
Das eine schließt das andere ja nicht aus.
Man sollte vielleicht beides machen.
Aber ihr kennt mich, ich schreibe keinem vor oder will keinem vorschreiben, was er machen soll.
Ihr fresst, was ihr wollt. Juckt mich nicht.
Ich glaube, gleich geht die Mikrowelle an.
So von der Zeit her.
Ich habe es irgendwie so im Gefühl.
Ich habe brutal Hunger schon.
Ich war gestern wieder unterwegs.
Long Run.
1.20 oder so.
Stunde 20 Minuten diesmal wieder.
und den Tag
da drauf, nachdem ich
Long Run habe, habe ich immer
übertrieben Hunger, ich meine seit ich
täglich Sport mache, habe ich eh
mehr Hunger, ja, aber
gerade nach den Tagen, also Samstags renne ich
ja immer Stunde 20, Stunde 30
teilweise
und bis zu 15 Kilometer
teilweise und
habe ich den Tag danach immer
so krass Hunger
Aber keine Bauchkrämpfe.
Nee, warum?
Was für eine Mikrowelle ich habe, weiß ich nicht.
Irgendeine billige Mikrowelle von Amazon.
Ach so, ja, ja, ja.
Aber das lag bestimmt nicht daran.
Wer weiß, an was das lag.
Nee, nee, kein Bauchweh.
Habe ich eigentlich selten.
Hatte ich früher öfters, aber noch nie wirklich schlimm.
Ja Leute, wir machen jetzt Schluss mit dem Stream.
Gleich gibt es Futter, gehe ich mal stark von aus.
Ich habe brutal Hunger.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob wir heute, morgen oder vielleicht auch nächste Woche...
Wir müssen Rust programmieren.
Nämlich die ganze Sache, die ganze Geschichte mit Herzfrequenz-Sensor auslesen über einen USB-Stick.
Und das werden wir in Rust rewriten
Wir haben es in Go
Halbwegs hingekriegt
Mehr schlecht als recht
Und jetzt wird das rewritten in Go
Da bin ich mal gespannt
Ob ich am ausrasten bin
Oder ob ich das nice finde
Wahrscheinlich beides
Chat ich hoffe euch hat der Stream gefallen
Wem es gefallen hat
Könnt mir jetzt ja ein Follow dalassen
Das würde mich sehr freuen.
Wie gesagt, grüne Pfeile sind mega motivierend.
Und außerdem stehe ich dann in eurer Liste, wenn ich online bin.
Links auf der Seite.
Dann könnt ihr sehen, wann der Wubblos am Start ist.
Und ich glaube, man kann auch eine Notification einschalten oder so.
Aber drauf geschissen.
Ich freue mich zumindest über jeden Follow.
Natürlich auch über jeden Sub und alles und sowieso.
Und ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Tschätke, wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.